He's go getting his cortisol spiked super hard by Ogre boy. Okay.
>> It's wrong, isn't it? Isn't it wrong? Wait, isn't it
wrong? I'm not relitigating 2024. You're projecting >> It's
not really a conversation. He wants to just like pummel them
to the ground. >> So, your claim that I'm trying to relitigate
the 2024 ELECTION IS WRONG, ISN'T IT? >> I'm done accommodating
the neurosis.
>> You're using the absence of evidence as evidence for
your claim. That's insane.
Okay, this is Pisco covering his fights with uh Ogre Boy. Apparently,
we have some Ogre Boy Pisco Twitter fights. Let's start first
with what I'm responding to and then just to just to get a little
sense of how annoying this [__] is.
This entire thing is so
So, in response to talking about Dems, Dems in Congress betraying
their voters massively, and this is by and large the focus of
Jenk UR, which is to mold about Democrats.
Let us not forget what Jenk said for months and months, which
was the real right-wing populist base. They're for real.
They care about different things than some Democrats, but we
agree on >> Shank like trusting these people was a lot.
I do think like sometimes you do need to go and like try
>> I think it was the key things. >> And what are
the key things? The key things are
>> Why is Ogre Boy defending Chank? I mean, I'll defend
Chen just probably not on the um like trusting the Trump coalition
to be honest with you. corruption
or certain populist programs like Medicaid,
Pentagon funding. And
I don't think Chen sold out to Trump. I think Cheng thought,
hey, there's a populist coalition here that's got like genuine
concern for the people, but they don't have genuine concern for
the people. They're animated by like way different concerns.
The populist thing is just what got them like to where they are.
But they are animated by group bias more than anything else.
>> No new wars. That's what the populous woods entails.
That's why after Kamla lost the election in 2024,
if you remember,
Jenkuger said, "Why do I feel so joyful and hopeful and optimistic?"
He said, "I feel so optimistic
because my main enemy was defeated."
And that's the corporate media.
That is the establishment.
They were defeated.
And I'd rather live in the populous woods
than the establishment prison. So what happened, Jenk?
I thought that we were in the populous woods. I thought that's
why you were so optimistic.
You were so optimistic because we're no longer in an establishment
prison.
Meanwhile, Donald Trump yesterday just said that Mark Lean uh
epitomized his MAGA. Just so you know.
I didn't know that, but that's >> Main allies right now
when it comes to defending the illegal unjustified war are Mark
Leven, Ben Shapiro, Sean
Wow. Is Pisco snarking on the right now? I didn't expect that.
I didn't think I was going to come in here and go, "Oh, boy,
shut the up." Pisco's right about them. Okay. I didn't think
that was going to happen. That's a little >> woods. They
said populace woods,
he said. And so I'm just wanting to get some acknowledgement
from Jenk.
Where is the rightwing? >> That's a joke. Obviously, you
can
criticize multiple. You criticize Mark Leven. You can criticize
Ben Shapiro without being concerned about their >> The
populist base that you assured us was for real. Your enemy, you
claim, the mainstream media, the donor class, was defeated in
the 2024 election. We were in the populous woods. These are your
words. Were you wrong, Ogre boy coming in to defend Jenk? Didn't
Jen come up with all this after Kamla lost as though that contradicts
anything I said? Did I say it was before Kamla lost or after?
I mean that
this ogre is always like fighting ghosts. I don't know why he
thinks to raise something that is totally irrelevant to my point.
You know, we can criticize statements made before Kamala.
>> Where is the right-wing populist base that you assured
us was for real? Your enemy, you claimed the en the mainstream
media in the donor class was defeated in the 2024 election. We
were in the populist woods. Your words, were you
I think Chank would just admit he is wrong, though.
Why is Ogre boy coming in here? Didn't Chank come up with all
this after Kamla lost? We have an illegal war of choice going
on and ample evidence to suggest Dem leadership at minimum isn't
fighting. Numerous ranking Dems willing to fund it. And we're
still trying to rub Chank's nose in it for smoozing with Kirk.
I mean, I don't mind Pisco. If Pisco is going to do like a hundred
tweets like this, I'd be annoyed.
But one is fine. One just being like, "Hey, Chank, what the what
what gives, bro?" I don't mind one. And he's going to spend a
lot of time on it. Feel kind of goofy. But it's important to
just get like Chank's little admission. I was wrong about this.
These people sucked. Anna apologized like two weeks ago. Yeah,
that's what I assumed is basically if you were paying any amount
of attention that you would see that like he was like Chank doesn't
seem like a guy when he [__] up.
Chank doesn't seem like a guy who would go who would to me I
he feels like the guy who go Pierce and go I up worse than anybody
Piers I did the I said I trusted these people and I look like
a idiot. I feel like that's Chank. No, wouldn't Chank be doing
that. lost and after Kla lost. There's actually nothing wrong
with criticizing a statement or a set of predictions about Trump
after Kamla lost. That's actually
>> uhoh. Jenk is coping. I
Believe it or not, the flow of time and normative value did not
stop
after Kamla lost >> and we just live in this I don't know
little fold. And
>> Pisco likes to do this. Pisco does
what we call this.
And it's annoying. It's annoying he's doing this
cuz
realistically, yes, this is
Please treat it with like the weight of irrelevance that it deserves.
It's an irrelevant statement, right? But Pisco will see something
that's like an irrelevant part to somebody's argument and he
will spend 5 minutes ruminating on it. It's like, dude, do you
have OCD? Like, what is your problem? Yeah, it's it's irrelevant
to the argument you're making. But just like go like, well, that's
stupid. And move on. I feel like he's going to spend a lot of
time on it. >> Ripple in time space that we can't
>> just we're going to go back.
Ogre's always like fighting. I don't know why he thinks to raise
something. >> Oh, even before this he'd already read it.
So probably 2450. >> That is totally irrelevant to my point.
>> You know, we can criticize statements made before Kla
lost and after Kamla lost. There's actually nothing wrong with
criticizing a statement or a set of predictions about Trump after
Kamla lost. That's actually okay to do. Believe it or believe
it or not, the flow of time and >> everyone agrees it's
been 30 seconds. normative value did not stop
after Kamla lost and we just live in this I don't know
little fold and ripple in time space that we can't acknowledge
and assess things that happen after
>> yep okay over 45 seconds >> I don't know what
he's responding to
>> we have an illegal war of choice going
>> what do you think that I've been talking about I've
been spending a lot of time covering the illegal war of choice.
So I don't know what the [__] you're on about. It
seems are both implicitly acknowledging that we're against this
war and I have explicitly done so in other replies to Jenk and
in coverage and ample evidence to suggest them leadership in
the at a minimum isn't
numerous ranking Dems willing to fund it and we're still trying
to rub Jenk's nose in it for sch smoozing with Kirk. So, I think
Ogre Boy is trying to say, well, it seems like your energy would
be better directed at the Dems who are totally complicit with
this rather than Chank who's totally against it the same way
you are, right? Like, hey, maybe we should pull in the same direction
on being against this war. That's probably the point he's trying
to make, right? I think that's the point he's trying to make
is, hey, if we're all, you know,
on this issue, if we all agree we should be pulling against the
Iran war right now, then maybe it's okay to criticize Dems and
maybe, you know, don't focus on CH so much. Focus on the actual
bad things happening. He was going to do the chew bubble gum
and whatever argument. Chew bubble gum and walk at the same time
argument. And >> so, a complete straw man.
A complete straw man. Did I say rub Jen's nose in it for sch
smoozing with Kirk? Though that's a piece of evidence to show
that he didn't understand >> It's not a straw, man. It's
it's like an example of the criticism you're making, right? That
he was trying to smoo with right-wingers saying they were actually
>> But no, the whole point was not that you're having a
social encounter, but the substantive belief and prediction.
The substantive belief and prediction that the right-wing populist
base is for real
is for real. and they're actually going to do the things that
we think are
like preventing. >> Okay, maybe I give him that ogre boy
is sweeping a little bit there for Chank that ogre boy like >> the
government from stopping to fund Medicaid
or stopping reigning Trump in.
These are all predictions that Jen had when we could actually
call them to account the same way ogre that you call other people
to account. libs mostly to account, dems mostly to account when
you feel like their statements are
etc., etc. To inform you, by the way,
as part of this criticism that Jenk is
is not just on establishment Dems, but specifically, do you guys
remember who? Not just establishment Dems. You remember specifically
who by name he was calling them out by name. Wasn't just establishment
Dems.
You guys remember going to be APAC affiliated Dems? >> No,
you're there. There's a delay. There's a delay. Nope. You didn't
see the stream. Well, I'll tell you then. Good lucker.
That's right. Bernie AOC.
Bernie AOC. The squad progressives. So, this is not an establishment
attack
on Jank U. Not at all.
Not at all. In a second, you're going to see even more how ridiculous
this insinuation is.
This insinuation is because well, I'll just show you right
My brother, so my first response to ogre boy, my brother, Jenk
said to come back in a year and to hold him accountable. Jenk
said to do that and let me get you to my tweet. Well, what is
this clip? This is a clip. Now, now who is Jen talking to? Just
notice who's Shank talking to here. Is Shank talking to some
establishment chill here? Who is he talking to?
Just note that. And note what he says here. >> Should go,
hey, you know what? Cut,
>> Medicare and medic. >> Sorry, I just laugh sometimes
watching because it's like
just let it play. It's going to all become obvious if you just
let it play. >> Don't worry about the Pentagon. >> So,
he's the name of the straight raid peace podcast was like so
perfect. Just just press play, bro. Quit yapping. Hit the play.
>> I can say that from the safety of my stream. I'd never
go in his chat and say that. If you ever say that in a streamer's
chat, you deserve to get >> The right-wing populist base
is gonna like be up in arms when the government tries to stop.
>> Hold on. That's you. Yeah, if you said that in my chat,
if you want to complain about me doing it, you will die. But
I will say it about Pisco on my stream all I like.
That's what we call hypocrisy.
>> Don't worry about the conflicts of interest. Don't worry
about cutting the Pentagon. Cut the the best parts of the budget
first. No, NO, NO. I JUST I GUESS WHERE you and I disagree is
I just do not believe that they actually are serious about like
any positive int like I don't believe they're going to cut the
Pentagon period and so that I think that maybe partly why come
down in a different place but also my position really is that
with >> so Crystal's explaining why she doesn't think the
administration is going to do any of this stuff and isn't going
to be um incentivized by the right-wing populist base. Let's
see the response >> this particular project because it
is so pernicious to just give cart launch to a group of billionaires
with massive conflicts of interest like some of the >> Yeah.
So like in in the greater scheme of this this is so dangerous
and pernicious we just need to be opposed to it. So this is what
Crystal is saying and look at what Jen says in response >> conflicts
of interest you can imagine. I think to me the most important
approach to that is just to to oppose it. But I I understand
where I get where you're coming from. >> Can I I want to
uh address something to the audience. Can I this my camera here?
Directly at the camera. Directly at the
>> Okay. Yeah. So, right-wing populist, it is now your
job to prove Crystal wrong. >> Go out and do it, y'all.
>> Right-wing populist, it is your job to prove Crystal
wrong. >> So, she doesn't believe you. And by the way,
almost no one on the me and Anna. >> So, he's addressing
the right-wing populist base directly into the camera. believe
you guys that you actually want to cut the Pentagon and that
you could pressure Elon Musk and Donald Trump and not just that
you want to cut the Pentagon, but that you can pressure them
to do it. So, not just Right. Right. And it's not >> OH,
WE'RE LISTENING TO JAKE SAY IT. YES, I know. Are you going to
quote word for word after he says it every single time you making
that? It's it's him saying not just that you want it, but that
you will be able to effectuate it. You hear me? So, it's both.
He stops himself to >> that left other than me and Anna
believe you guys that you actually want to cut the Pentagon and
that you could pressure Elon Musk and Donald Trump to cut the
>> So, are you going to prove the left wrong or are you
going to prove them spectacularly right? Am I going to have to
come on here and apologize to Crystal for ever believing in any
right-wing
>> Stop bullying Pisco now. Uh, we'll see because I think
this gets really rough. He starts like going hard on Ogre Boy.
So, listen. And >> I
we'll see. Maybe this is all on call >> sucker. Those guys
are liars. They all they wanted to do was increase the Pentagon,
have more wars, more corruption, and they never held Trump accountable.
We waited four long years for them to hold him accountable. And
all they did was kiss his ass, and show that they don't really
believe in freedom. They said all this stuff about freedom, but
they never meant it. They said all this stuff about drain the
swamp, but they never meant it. They said all this anti-war stuff,
but they never meant it. We're going to come back on here in
one year, two years, four years, and we're going to keep doing
a check. So, if right-wing populists are frauds, I'm going to
say, Crystal, you were right. They were frauds all along.
>> But I don't think so. I think they actually mean it.
>> So, it's Jenk who said we'll be back here in a year.
It's Jenk who said we need to do a check to see if they're for
real, if they're against wars, if they're against corruption,
if they're against increases to Pentagon spending. And before
when he was talking about the other programs that actually benefit
and maybe some right-wing populist pay lip service to like Medicaid,
think like Josh Holly and these guys. That was jank saying, "Let's
do check-ins.
Let's test if it's for real." There was a criteria by which he
expected himself to be judged and that he expected the right-wing
populist base to be judged. That's him. And what do we have?
They cut Medicaid by hundreds of billions of dollars.
MAGA didn't give a [__] MAGA supported the big beautiful
bill. Did you hear any MAGA people?
Even Nick Fuentes, right? If you want to talk about people willing
to criticize the administration,
he was lukewarm in favor of the big beautiful bill because it
funded ICE and
Did you hear them ever say, "Oh no, not our Medicaid.
Not our Medicaid."
No, they didn't say that. Even though a lot of them are the ones
who are most likely to be affected by those cuts after Trump
leaves office
cynically with that timetable, massive increase in Pentagon spending.
Now, I personally am fine with a big military budget. I think
it should be efficient. I think there's probably a lot of To
speak of waste, fraud, and abuse. Doge was told not to touch
the DoD. >> Oh, is that that's like the number one place
you could find waste, fraud, and abuse is the DoD.
Dude, have you seen
uh was it Thomas Massie? He was talking about like that $70,000
bag of bushings.
Dude, that's where that's where all the waste, fraud, and abuse
is.
Listen, don't you look into waste, fraud, and abuse, but don't
touch the weight the waste, fraud, and abuse department. Okay?
Don't don't do that. >> Keep that in mind.
So, I definitely want to make things efficient. I don't think
that we should like massively cut Pentagon. Funny, but that's
a policy difference, but that's something that the the you know,
the populace really think is a good idea. is massive decrease
in Pentagon funding. >> Excuse me. Sorry. Excuse me.
Do you ever just choke on nothing? >> That's happened before.
>> You ever just choke on nothing? We had a massive increase
in Pentagon spending. >> He's not fine. >> They're
going to propose a supplemental,
>> Is he fine? I don't support that. Has anyone said, "Oh,
no. Not the Pentagon
>> Oh, he recovered. Oh, dude. I've never been able to
Oh, I just went back to the P the stream. Whoops. Hold on.
Hold on. Pentagon spending were the last words I heard. Hold
on. Pentagon.
Pentagon spending
>> for real. If they're against wars, if they're against
corruption, if they're against increases to Pentagon spending
and before when he was talking about the other programs that
actually benefit >> Excuse me. Sorry. >> Excuse me.
Do you ever just choke on
>> He's like kind of dying there. >> You ever just
choke on nothing?
>> He's still dying. >> We had a massive start talking.
>> Hang on. Spending. He's still I feel like he's still
dying and he tries to go forward and he pushes through it. He
actually pushes through it. That's crazy.
I can't I have to like I have to like clear my throat and stop
if I choke on something. Yeah. >> They're going to propose
a supplemental, >> Dude, he's still in pain right now.
He is still in pain.
It's not gone yet.
>> And back. >> Right there. Oh, that's where he
>> Watch, watch, watch. Right here. >> Propose a
supplemental, too. >> Right there. Right there. where he
like stops like
he like swallows it down and then he's >> will support
that. Has anyone said, "Oh no, not the Pentagon spending."
Who has said that? Who the hell has said we're going to
get angry at Trump because of the pent Pentagon spending has
gone up? Of course, it's gone up.
No one have the MAGA right-wing populist base
been angry at the
like
most blatant corruption we've ever seen.
They can't defend they can defend it in >> I thought I
like he's just spitting but like I don't think Ogre boy is talking
about this. So I get where he's coming from. Yes, that they were
fake. They were fake and Chank should feel bad. >> Any
respect. It is so corrupt it'll make you blush. the crypto schemes,
the rugpulls,
the airplane, the use of leverage on media, the use of leverage
on foreign states, the massive trading spikes before tariffs
are announced and other policies are announced. Have any of them
complained? They don't think that he's corrupt. They love him.
>> And have they made any impact on the foreign policy
intervention and new wars that Trump is starting, including now,
most recently this war in Iran. But that's not the only one,
right? They weren't giving a [__] on the 12-day war.
They didn't give a [__] about the one-day war in
Venezuela and what happened. I thought that was based
They don't give a [__] about him continuing to be
aggressive towards neighbors, Canada, Greenland.
>> This is not something that they give a [__]
about. >> And it's like 90%. As expected, I mean, I called
it the day they started. Like, they're they're all going to fall
in line. You have some rumble rumble.
>> It's like, let's be fair, okay, >> but you haven't
seen a massive turning away of the MAGA loyalist. But here's
what I think will happen, right? Here's what I think will happen.
Let's go to this is not, right? So, understand whose side I'm
on. I'm on Crystal Ball's side here. I'm on AOC side and Bernie
side here. I'm saying, "Hey, these rightwingers, they're actually
not your friend. These MAGA elites actually hate us. They want
to deport you. They want to denaturalize you and deport you.
They despise you. It's Dank who is trying to curry favor with
the right. What I'm offering is a critique from the left. This
is a leftwing critique. So there's nothing wrong with calling
him out and looking for accountability. But you want to know
the sad thing? This is the sad thing, right? Let's say that Trump
in about a week. In about a week, Trump says, "You know what?
Let's cut our losses and leave Iran."
Who thinks Who thinks that they know what Jen's response to that
would be? Next week, Trump says, "You know what? Uh, I don't
be quick. I'm gone. >> At least he pulled out. At least
he fixed it. At least he's Look, he he >> and leaves."
What would Jake's response be? Say it in the chat. It's your
>> He learned. He He fixed it. He He fixed it. give you
uh five seconds.
Got to give him credit. Yep. Got to give him credit. See, I told
you, >> dude. I would straight up say I would say got to
give him credit purely on the basis of like anything that stops
the global economic meltdown that's about to ensue. I support
and I would just I would say literally anything to prevent it.
So, >> he was pressured. The base pressure him. And so,
he uh >> not quite the same as what Shank's >> You
got to give Trump credit. He got out. Not >> quite the
same.
>> I'm undicated now. Doesn't that just raise your blood
pressure? You know, this would happen
after he starts an illegal war with a goal of regime change and
let's say for reasons related to his corruption, reasons related
to personal um benefit, reasons related to well, he doesn't want
to commit fully because it's like very bad for his future. >> He's
like, you know what, we're out.
Jen would be giving him credit, right? Joe Biden stopped this
regional war. Joe Biden resisted
Israel's um efforts to try to >> True. Pisco Pisco is about
to ask his chat the most important question about Joe Biden.
Can you find me a picture of Joe Biden kissing that wall?
Answer,
no.
>> Thank you. Please go this out. >> Zero credits.
>> God bless Irish Catholics. >> Have you ever seen
tweet credit to Joe >> The last the last line of resistance.
Irish Catholics. >> He didn't go full war. You guys know
Jake would say Jake would say, "See, I was right. I was right."
Even if, by the way, Trump goes in with special forces or I don't
know what to say this exhibitionary force into um parts of Iran.
And even if it's the last like three or four more months, I mean,
there's there's no limit. He was pushed finally by the by the
base to get out of it. When the base is telling him, "No, we
approve." Right? The base is telling him we approve. The base
is behind him. It's not the right-wing populist base that's pushing
back. It's the Gulf States. It's independents that he might need
for Republicans to win.
Right? Those are the potential.
>> Wait, Biden actually didn't go to the wall. You have
there is no picture of Biden touching the wall, kissing the wall,
nothing. zero pictures of Joe Biden doing that which is particularly
impressive because he's been a politician for like 50 years >> forces
but it's not his base he's moving his base he is making this
he's opening in other words a
what's the um permission structure a permission structure to
support neocon policies
which we were assured were like a bygone past where is this populist
as understood from like the Trumpian and mega perspective I think
he was giving credit to Bid for not going to war in the past
maybe he did maybe he did haven't seen it recently haven't seen
it recently where he's like you Oh, we're all about O Biden.
Dot dot dot. He didn't he was involved here.
He would give Trump more credit for getting out of the war after
getting in the war than never getting in the war in the first
place. Guys, you call him a war. It's screams when he lives leaves
around. Yeah, I can I can totally see it. So, who was right here?
Was it Crystal Ball being skeptical, being critical, being
I don't think Hold on. I literally don't think Ogre Boy even
disagree. So, speaking of straw manning,
I don't think Ogre Boy disagrees with that. I think he's just
saying prioritywise.
He's making sort of a
he's sort of making the argument people make at Hutch, right?
I feel like that's what's happening here pretty obviously. He's
not saying Chank was right.
He's saying don't go after Chank even if Chen was wrong. Don't
go after Chank cuz it's not worth your time. Go after the people
supporting this war. >> Had this fanciful notion of reigning
in Trump's bicos.
>> So I again this is kind of just got offer. It's >> who
was right, Crystal or Jen who said, "We'll check in in a year."
Well, I'm checking in >> anyway. I just say, "Yo, what's
what's your problem, dude? To do this?" >> Oh, no. Omega
Ogre disagrees now. >> And now look at this liar. It's
a lie. I'm just saying it seems like you're demanding some concession
before you'll touch this line about the role Democrats are playing
in the fight against the war or lack thereof because of the post
general election drain scope of Jake, right? I don't care if
he slipped Kirk tongue on stage. It seems out of place. What's
the lie? The lie is that I'm unwilling to attack Democrats or
be critical of Democrats for not fighting hard enough on this
war. And everyone who watches me knows that that's a [__]
lie. I was pinging Jared Moskuit on Twitter, by the way. Not
just my stream. On Twitter, ping Jar Musk. Why do they out face?
Why? Why are you changing? Why are you saying you're not going to
sign on the war power resolution? Not just that, by the way.
Um talking [__] about the potential for Democrats
to vote for the funding of the supplemental on stream. I've been
incredibly critical Democratic leadership in their statement.
>> Okay, that's still that's literally still not a um a
disagreement with any of the things Pisco is railing on there,
which is just funny. It's just a little funny because of
Oh, wait. Oh, he's on a live and learn Twitter account. I was
like, why is he following himself?
That was weird to me. Why is he following himself? But he's on
a live and learn Twitter account. I see. I got it. >> I
critical
statements about funding. So, he's just lying, right? And also,
none of this is contingent on me getting something from Jen to
do this, right? I'm not like them. I don't need to get an apology
or a concession or acknowledgement wrong before I'm willing to
criticize Democrats if I feel they're doing something like not
right. That's not me. Can you imagine having that level of pride?
saying, "I'm unwilling to comment on a completely collateral
thing in my own life, in my own commentary," until another commentator
said they're wrong. >> Total projection. Total projection
that this is like some kind of like, "Well, I won't critique
Democrats because Jank U was wrong. The Republicans were worse."
No, I criticize Democrats. Everyone sees me do it. And in fact,
Ogre Boy knows I do this and especially including this war because
I know he's my coverage. He knows I'm on the war and he knows
what I've said and he's defended me before when I criticized
Democrats and so he knows I'm willing. >> I I said what
it seemed like Ogre was doing. I don't know why Ogre didn't just
say what I said. Ogre should have just said what I said. Hey,
pull in the same direction. We're all against this war, right?
But ogre said something about Pisco not being like need concession
before you touched the line about the role Dems are playing.
Yeah, I think that's just wrong to do this. Not standing the
fact that Jugger has uh maintained this position of populist
Woods for all these months. It's a complete and >> why
is Pisco putting his knee on Jank's
>> Well, it seems like Chank won't concede that he was
wrong, but I'm being >> a complete and total lie. It doesn't
make any sense whatsoever. That's why I say I call it duns all
the time. I was at Moscow recently on his slip on war power resolution
when at least multiple times on stream criticizing the war. Retweeted
fifer on Washington's not fun supplemental. Where's my apology
and look at look at these paragraphs bro you've interacted with
him here on Twitter and he's supposed to know that. How? No.
No. What do you mean he's Jen is supposed to know that? It's
not about what Jen thinks about what you claimed. You claimed
that I'm unwilling to touch this line, right? You're demanding
some concession before you'll touch this line.
I've also seen some of this when you were reacting to Jen's video.
Oh, so you know that I was reacting to J. And when I did react
to Jen's video, I absolutely positively was agreeing with him
on some of the criticisms of speific Democrats. Absolutely positively
I was he makes a claim you call it a lie. Someone in your chat
would correct you. You give a well that happened if that happened
that stupid or just because that doesn't mean the whole party
and then you go back. So this is another
>> Oh okay. Hold on. Hold on. >> Some of this when
you were >> I didn't see he went down to the next um >> what
Jen thinks about what you claimed. You claimed that I'm unwilling
to touch this line. Right. You're demanding some concession before.
You'll touch this
>> I've also seen some of this when you were reacting to
Jen's video. Oh, so you know that I was reacting to J's video
and when I did react to Jane's video, I absolutely positively
was agreeing with him on some of the criticisms of specific Democrats.
Absolutely positively I was. He'd make a claim, you call it a
lie, someone in your chat would correct you. You give a well
that happened if that happened that's stupid or just because
leaders did that doesn't mean the whole party and then you go
right. So this is another lie.
I was skeptical about the claim on Ruben Diego and I wanted to
see what what GGO said. I out of my own initiative did that.
So he's like this was this pattern where Jank would say something
and you would like say that's stupid. That's not real. That's
not real. and then someone would correct it and then I would
be like oh well I guess whatever fine
when it was out of my own initiative that I said well let me
just double check trust but verify the Ruben claim said you know
yeah I agree that's a bad statement but that doesn't necessarily
extend to the whole Democratic caucus which is true which is
was my position is my position and the same thing with leadership
leadership is not the whole party and so him presenting it as
a pattern that I was like constantly debunked by the chat as
though as opposed to having an initiative of my own to check
and verify what was saying being willing to hear him out being
open-minded not closed-minded open-minded enough to watch it
and to actually agree with some of the things that he was saying
that's speaking against me. Now I'm I was constantly debunked
by my own chat and like so that's a second lie. This is a second
lie. This characterization is a knowing and intentional falsehood.
>> I've seen some of this I've also seen some of this when
you were reacting to Trin's video. You'd make a claim. You'd
call it a lie. Someone in your chat would correct you and you'd
give a well if that happened that's stupid. Or well just because
the leadership did that it doesn't mean that's the whole party.
And then you go right back to to how wrong Chen or how Chank
still is wrong. Ooh,
I feel like that would be very easy for Ogre Boy to verify
if that did happen. So, what I'm guessing is Pisco doesn't feel
like that's, you know, how he works most of the time. But, if
that did happen and Pisco is saying, "You're a you're knowingly
and intentionally lying right now." That would be very embarrassing.
I wonder I wonder who's got it wrong here cuz that is that is
a claim from Ogre Boy that's on the table. >> Layers of
lies. So, this is a lie. Complete total lie. And if you watch
me do it, you would know it's a lie. He's claiming he watched
it. Obviously, no video here. Just a screenshot. Just a screenshot.
No video of this happening. Just a screenshot
of this pattern. >> Dude, Ogre Boy could totally body him
here if he if this did happen. Ogre boy could body him. >> Downplaying
lobbying money is wild. Especially calling it Zog memes.
They literally have the position that Israel runs our country.
That is their unironic position. You want to know what Zogs?
That's not that's not the position. I don't even think that's
Cheng's position. It's like people will take like a term of art
like basically when you say the Zog thing where you say like
these people influence all of our decisions. These people we
our our politicians are at the behest of these people. It's like
the same dude. It's like saying um hey you're funded by the CO
network. You're like owned by big oil. Oh you're saying big oil
runs the whole you're saying big big oil controls everything
in our country. Big oil controls our country. It's like, dude,
really? Like, no, it's a little further than it's it's like not
quite that,
dude. The occupied government stuff is not saying, at least in
2026,
it is not saying that it's just like it's mind control. Mind
control. I'm so tired of this. It's really not. If you want to
argue that that's B, then explain to me
why despite how unpopular support for Israel is, the government
is without question immediately immediately supporting anything
they need to for Israel. Explain the dissonance.
If there's not something going on there, explain. And by the
way, when I say something going on there, I mean, if they're
not being swayed by contributions and by long-term like persistent
lobbying, as in I'm going to make all these arguments for why
this is good. It's not mind control. It is somebody, dude, if
you have if you have people offering you money. It's the same
thing. Imagine this was a streamer. Imagine the politicians are
streamers, because they basically are. Imagine they're getting
a bunch of money and a bunch of information showing them exactly
why it's really important to support Israel and they're not getting
anything like that from the other side. Which direction is their
opinion going to sway?
It's very obvious
stands for
Zionist occupied government. It is their literal position that
Zionists control our government. That is to say, Israel is running
the show in the White House. Now, Israel has a great deal of
influence in the White House for sure. Trump is BB's. I'm happy
to say that. The reason why
That's no different. It's just It's just like, bro, the implication
that Chank thinks it's like mind control is so disingenuous.
It's so embarrassing.
but this is what you have to do because EVERYBODY'S SO TERRIFIED.
OH NO, someone said I agree with Nick Fes on something. Oh no.
Oh no. I have to find somebody to attack. Look at how bad these
anti-semites are, >> dude. It's like that's what has to
happen. It's like it's just transparent. That's what I figured
this was. That's what I think it is. Okay. I'm kind of I'm kind
of done with this specific thing where people are like, "Oh,
and I'm done, by the way. I'm not just done with it. I'm done
accommodating the neurosis is what I'm done with." Okay? I'm
done accommodating the neurosis.
The fact that you're insanely neurotic about this and you need
people to agree with everything you're saying so that you can
feel like you're going to stop having a panic attack. Yeah, I
don't care. I don't care about your panic attack. Have your panic
attack. Okay? I will be I will be hyperbolic about this. I will
make jokes about this. I will do memes about this.
I'll do this very offensive voice that complains about anti-semitism
all the time. I'll do that, too, because I don't care.
All right. Now, I'll denounce any actual bigotry, any actual
like um like calls for violence, calls for
I don't know, just any actual genuine like racial hatred. It's
just stupid. But I It's just such a joke. Okay. It's such a joke
when these people are constantly
Oh, this is like Zog. This is You're saying like Zog.
You're doing Zog memes. You're doing Zog memes right now. Shut
up. Why the zog memes are stupid is because it's a way of sweeping
for MAGA. It's a way of sweeping agency from these corrupt
who are getting kickbacks and donations. Yeah, the donations
are definitely part of it. The lobbying is definitely part of
it. No one's denying that. The ZOG meme isn't the AP pack money
has no influence. That's disingenuous. That's disingenuous. That's
not what I said. What I said is the Apac paragraph answer. And
you can if you had a good example of me doing this, you would
just show the clip. But the explanation I gave was very clear.
Just putting this down to oh Apac APC APAC. That is too simplistic.
It's not accurate.
So I never said that lobbying, that donations, that campaign
stuff that is not relevant to how people do things. That's not
my position. The issue here is that you have a president and
only one of your neighbors is taking advantage of that by sucking
his so that he can get Trump to do something that Americans over
for Israel's benefit. As long as your country is acting totally
to the positive benefit of Israel
at the detriment of America, then when it's BB convincing Trump
to do things, it's fine to call it Israel's war. It's fine to
say Israel pushed this. It's fine to say all of these things
because identifying that, identifying the cause, the core cause,
and saying these are the people benefiting, pointing that out
is important to making sure it doesn't happen again.
Like holy [__] You can see me debating actual justice
warrior saying that Trump's going to gonna be BB's. The Zog memes
are, "Oh, it's just all Israel." It's thought terminating. It's
a way to depress
um you know, our potential action. It's like a comfort blanket.
It's it's saying like, "Oh, we have no power. We're out of control."
No.
No. You have total power. You should anybody who is
any Zogbot should be voted out of government. Exactly. Yes. You
have all the power to vote these zogbots out of government.
You have all the power in the world to vote them out. >> Oh,
no. we had a power when we elected
someone like Trump who was going to listen to Israel's >> saying
the Zog thing doesn't terminate that saying saying that even
if even if you're unironically saying Zog I don't think it doesn't
terminate that but like using it as a as a joke as a thing you
point at that everybody laughs at everybody gets nope that doesn't
that doesn't terminate thoughts that's every everybody can see
that they have like a duty to make sure this doesn't happen again
they have a duty to vote in a way that makes sure this makes
sure this doesn't happen again. Or at least I assume that's the
people we're all talking to. I know my audience gets >> Who's
going to do because he's corrupt or because he's influencable
or because he's you can charm him very easily. And also the Apac
memes don't describe sometimes tensions that people don't want
to accept that exist between the Trump position and the Israel
position which do exist.
It's inconvenient for the Apac Zog um single-minded proponent
as though
knows this. Everybody knows this. That's why you lean into calling
Trump BB's because you hope that that insecurity in the back
of this dumb brain will eat away at him enough that he pulls
out of this war because he is his own agent, but he is an incredibly
like he's an incredibly um oh he's a massive dupe. He's a mark
so he could be tricked into doing anything,
right? And so you're hoping to do your own little mind trickery
there, okay, and convince him to pull out of the war by doing
this. It's basically the same thing in reverse obviously right
>> Trump and administration would never have tension I
don't say that the tension is reliable resolved in favor of the
American foreign policy but just that there is and has been reported
not just by credulous news organizations or mainstream media
but reputable well I should say but also by reputable and more
establishment
uh reporters New York Times report on that it just is true
and so this is just utter bubus as well it does like unfortunately
The other thing that you have to add on in here is when you say
the the Zog thing when you do the ZGO memes, why it's not just
your even your representatives. Why is Larry Ellison able to
lay down all of the collateral for his son to buy every media
conglomerate that exists? And why is that all being pushed through?
Hello. >> Doesn't describe my position. It's me saying
that it's too simplistic to say APAC APAC AP. Another example
of that is Chris Murphy takes Apac money. Other Democrats do
and they're not all horrible on this issue. Chris Murphy, I think,
is one of the best on this issue. I talked about how Blumenthal
even notwithstanding again big Apac recipient
notwithstanding that
has come out and and done some important signals about where
the the administration has is after these like sort of war conversations
that are happening and that explaining APAC APAC APAC is thought
terminating it makes it's inoculating it's almost like making
you >> Oh man, could you imagine if Trump was
let's say let's say Trump is like approving coal plants like
all over the Midwest. just coal plants, coal plants, coal plants.
Carbon emissions going through the roof. And then you're like,
"Oh, look at, you know, it actually turns out the coal mining
industry, the the coal lobby is actually donating way more money
than anybody else." And all of these politicians, they've been
doing this work for like a long time. They've been talking to
all these politicians for years, for decades, even some of them.
And maybe it has something to do with all of this coal lobbying.
Maybe it's the coal lobbying. And and Peace goes like, "Yeah,
but this guy took like this guy took like a million dollars from
the coal lobby." And he's saying like Cole is like bad sometimes.
Okay. But are we ignoring the like obvious scope and sweep of
the trend? Are we ignoring like the very obvious thing happening
here and saying like actually there's sort of like one case where
this person didn't work totally in concert with the coal lobby?
That's that's really not evidence of anything. That's not my
position. Like
it's in my opinion it's thought terminating to to argue the thought
terminating element. Like if you sat down, like just ask Pisco,
if you sat down with Anaka Kasparian, do you think she would
just say that it's hopeless? Do you even believe that she would
say the things you're saying that it's hopeless? You have no
power. Just one, they control everything.
You think Ana Kasparian is saying that? Cuz you're implying it.
That's unironically their position. It's a Zionist occupied government.
You can't do anything. You're powerless.
I'm pretty sure an Kasparian would not be saying that. If I go
load up her content, it would not be saying you're powerless.
You can't do anything. The one it's over. In fact, I'm pretty
sure I wouldn't be hearing Anakas Baron talk about the at all.
She does say that, but she's just frustrated. I would imagine
if she says that it's a joke and she is frustrated or it's like
uh yeah, it's like a vent. She goes, "That's not actually true,
but I do feel like that sometimes, right?" Yeah, I I could understand
if she said it like I mean I do the jokes, too. But it's like
it's it's not the jokes. You like Donald Trump is an agent,
right? But the problem is, the problem is, okay, you have a snake
oil salesman. You have a
if you have a family member, okay, who's dying of cancer and
some swindler comes along and takes a bunch of their money trying
to sell them homemade remedies.
Your family members are and you should blame your family member.
But I'm actually more worried about the totally morally bankrupt
piece of that ripped them off. That's what I'm angry about. Okay.
And that's what you should be angry about. That's what you should
actually be concerned about. That's keeping your eye on the ball.
Who is benefiting from the
cancer patient in
Okay. Who is the swindler who is destroying your country? Who
is taking advantage of your country, spending your tax dollars
to secure the the well-being of his own citizens? Who's doing
that?
Keep your eye on the ball. Okay.
And yes, you should vote out the person, the decision maker who's
allowing that spending to happen. You should absolutely do that.
That should be your top priority.
But your anger should be with the person with the underlying
like
the underlying people trying to sell that idea to your government.
Yes, it should be because that is what will actually carry through
to the next administration and the next administration and the
next administration. Right? You could get super mad about Republicans
not caring about climate change, but how about you focus on the
Coke network and how they're paying all these to be performatively.
Nobody has a problem with that. Everybody's behind that. Everybody,
nobody has any issue with calling out the Coke network in what
2008, 2009. Everybody understood, right? But now that the same
principle is being applied, oh well, now it's Zog memes and now
this is really thought terminating and terrible. Guys, shut up.
your position in this in the thought term actually talking about
some racial ethnic scapegoat as opposed to asking the question
why Republican money is going to dem primary races. What are
you talking about? I'm I'm happy with that question. It's just
not relevant to anything we're saying. And I take the position
that shouldn't take back money and they and I'm well aware that
they're attempting to interfere in the the Illinois whatever
race Illinois 9 or seven race. So all of this is totally off
base in terms of my position. Has nothing to do with what I'm
responding to which is his false lies. Not going to apologize
because I told no lies. You didn't tell lies. Provable lies.
I owe you comments how you're interacting here because you have
a vote to pick with his stupid diales with rightwing rightwingers
are supposed to election. I just think it's wild because right
now he's making he's more right than wrong about this. Again,
always keep an eye on like this weasel language. Total weasel
language. He's more right about this than wrong about this. What
you mean the conflict in general? What do you mean the point
I brought up? The point I brought up was
match Apac to make sure to drop cat A.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> Hold him to account on this
right. >> I haven't seen any reaction to that by the way.
Anyone can load me up with those. >> His thinking is it's
about sides. It's about sides about group think. That's what
this is about. It's group think. He's more right generally about
this conflict. He's more right generally. He's more, you know,
quote unquote on the left than the politicians. And so I'm going
to give him some cover. That's what it's all about. Even though
my comment isn't, Jen, you're more wrong about this conflict
than Republicans or Jen, you're more wrong about that. I never
said that. I never claimed that his general thought pattern on
this war is more or less wrong. I didn't make that assessment.
The only claim I'm making has to do with his false prediction,
false assessment.
I bring him to the point. You claim that sink goes dismant before
peace will touch this line about uh the role devs are playing
in this fight against the war lack thereof. That's not true because
I do touch that line including on Twitter. You were wrong about
that, right? So I'm just quoting from him. These are his words.
His accusation to me,
right? It's it's his words. No, because so you weren't wrong.
So you weren't wrong about me being unwilling to touch that line
because all right, let's see. Because Shank was saying where
the Dems are now and what the [__] are they doing
and you're popping in to talk about 2024 and showing an understanding
of the influence of lobbying leaves me dumbfounded. Word salad.
I I don't know what's wrong with this guy's brain. Word salad.
What does this have to do with anything? showing an understanding
of the influence of lobbying leaves me dumbfounded. Is that your
claim about how dumbfounded you are or not dumbfounded you are?
The first part of this just describing Yeah. and then you're
popping in to talk about not the 2024 election about his predictions
about what's going to happen in 2025 2026 and during the Trump
administration not about 20.4
one IQ did I say oh you're wrong about you're wrong about um
who you voted for for the election who you nominated or who he
supported Kamala in the election. The point about bringing it
to his predictions is what he said was going to happen in the
future not about his decision on 2024. It was his comments afterwards
saying, "Hey, I feel optimistic. I feel hopeful. Look, we're
in the right-wing populist or we're in the populist woods and
the rightwing populist base is for real." And that's why in the
future we're going to see Elon Musk and Donald Trump, they're
going to listen to the populist base. They're going to lower
Pentagon. I think that there's a good chance they're going to
lower Pentagon funding because the right popular space really
is for real and there really will pressure him in that direction.
That's what I'm talking about. The predictions for the future.
So, I'm like, those are Oh, hang on a second. You saying you
touch on things is doing a lot of heavy lifting. So, he's saying
that I claiming that I touch on it. It's like you're doing a
lot of heavy lifting with touch. Like, I picked touch in a kind
of sinister way. Like I picked this word touch touch touch on
to try to like evade responsibility for something like to keep
it ambiguous about how much it is that I cover a particular thing.
>> Sorry I'm sending some messages in the background here
too real quick but I got to go back to the department
because right when popular space really is for real and there
really will
>> that's what I'm talking about is the predictions for
the future. So I'm like those are oh hang on a second you saying
you touch on things is doing a lot of heavy lifting. So he's
saying that I claiming that I touch on it. It's like you're doing
a lot of heavy lifting with touch. Like I picked touch in a kind
of sinister way like I picked this word touch on to try to like
evade responsibility for something like to keep it ambiguous
about how much it is that I cover a particular thing. Understand
that right? So he's saying you saying you touch on things is
doing a lot of heavy lifting. >> Keep an eye on this weasly
language. >> Like there's something wrong with me using
touch on. But guys
>> who said touch on or touch this line? Touch. Who said
touch?
The reason I use touch is because he used touch. That's the metric
that he's judging me saying. You're unwilling unless you get
this concession to touch on this line. So he's calling me out
for using this terminology touch. I'm just literally repeating
back your phrasing your terms. That's what I'm doing. But I clearly
am willing to critique Democrat members on multiple platforms
including Twitter on this wars. You were wrong when you said
I wouldn't touch on that. You're trying to pivot. Now I submit
to the audience. Am I trying to pivot? Is my entire point this
for this exchange man? Why are you saying that I'm unwilling
to critique Democrats touch on or whatever this line is when
you just by the way watched me do that? This shows that he watched
me do that, right? So that's why it's a knowing intentional falsehood.
It's knowing and intentional. It's not just, oh, I was wrong
about it. He is claiming to have seen me review this content
and criticized Dems. Also, I brought to his attention other Twitter
post. You ever said anything vice? You're trying to pivot to
if you ever said anything vice what you're doing in the above
interaction with Jenk. I don't even know what that means. And
even then, Mr. Prosecutor, whenever you hear these, he's kind
of like Mr. Prosecutor, Mr. Pro. Just notice when people like
aren't on point, aren't really, >> dude. He's just he stops
on like every little thing. every single little thing. >> They're
just like kind of saying whatever. It's one thing if you you're
admitting leadership is out of touch or not in the moment versus
dismissing that they're standing in the way of the war power
resolution. Well, it depends who it is you're talking about or
trying to debate foo out of it. Again, not responsive, but I'm
I'm happy to critique leadership if they're think they're doing
it. And certainly membership. I I criticize membership that was
voting against it. I there's there are receipts of me doing this.
It's not up for debate 100%. Booker and Schiff are the only ones
that have stuck to a hell no. I'm actually surprised how much
of a spine Booker grew who the asked. Murphy's against it, but
still more process and pulseing complaints. False. False. Just
confabulating. Hasn't spent any time looking at what Murphy is
saying at all. But those names are the minority, not the majority.
Just absolutely disgraceful. No, I'm sure no homework done on
here. I'm sure no homework done here. I'm dealing only with the
false name. They're asking for concession before I'm willing
to do a particular thing. That's what is a dirty lie. You should
retract. I've already explained. I was judging your interaction
in the moment because you absolutely weren't engaging with what
Cheng was saying. That's just the facts. So, a third lie. We're
going to get to that in a second. But this is how you read it.
So, I'll submit to the audience. What do you think? What's the
best way to read this claim? I'm just saying it seems like you're
demanding some concession before you'll touch this line about
the role Democrats are playing in the fight against the war lack
thereof because of his post-election drains scope. Do you think
that that's best read that what he meant to say there was in
this specific
>> He's go getting his cortisol spiked super hard by ogre
boy. Okay.
Absolutely cortisol maxing right now. >> In this specific
interaction, you're unwilling to address Democrat faults until
Jenk specifically. Jen hasn't responded to me unless he gives
a concession. And that if asked by Jen, I would be unwilling
to do that even not saying that he hadn't given a concession.
Or is the best way to read this as I generally am unwilling to
push this line until I get concessions from people like Jake.
There's no qualification there. No equivocation.
Nothing of the sort. You just say it flatly. That's the best
way to interpret it. And then finally, this J I say the third
lie. Third lie. You you weren't engaging with what Jen was saying.
That's just facts. I'm not willing to engage with what Jen is
saying. You just posted you just posted me reacting to Jen's
entire video when we absolutely did engage with what Jen was
saying. When you're talking when you're lying about how I react
to what Jen is doing, it's proves that I am willing to engage
with Jen. pretty sure he's talking about the in on interest just
in Twitter,
>> The same and to give the push back his lack of concession,
but also yes, I'm willing to engage with the words that Tank
is using. Now, in this particular
>> I don't include in this tweet, hey, I agree with you
on some things about Democrats. Why should I have to? And why
is the fact that I don't why would that show that I'm unwilling
to just It is the worst set of dishonest tactics where you're
like not just reading into things I'm saying, but reading into
the fact I don't say something in a way that is like so counter
to who I am in my personality.
If I don't want to talk about something, I'll literally say,
"I don't want to talk about this. I don't talk about this." You
don't have to guess with me. I will tell you, I don't like to
talk about this. And then he's like, "Oh, you think Jake watches
your Come on. You're not this up to." So, he's like, "Oh, I was
just saying you're unwilling to with Jank because uh Jank wouldn't
have seen the video that you engaging with it. And so, you're
twisting himself into a pretzel." Hold
Uh I just I want to respond to his tweet really quick before
we go further on this because I'm trying to read this in the
background. I realize if I just read it on stream, then I can
then I can react more fully to what Pisco is actually talking
about. Okay. Okay, so we'll just read this real quick. It's a
trippy response to Auggie in his latest video exposing we watch
this exposing that Dioro's hypocrisy argument came only after
he realized he stuck his foot in his mouth calling Anie's impression
offensive/b bad. Augie's offering a perspective that kind of
defends his friend and I think Augi's being a good friend in
doing so. This is just a post talk rationalization blah blah
blah blah
I'm so it's so I can't disagree with this stance without it being
because
uh I must defend a friend of mine. Um,
disagree with the rationalization
of your how do I want to put this? Do you disagree with what
his argument on why uh do you disagree with his arguments? I'm
trying to say like basically does Auggie actually disagree with
what Chipy said or does he just disagree with the frame the way
Chili flamed Augie's disagreement framing of with his um explanation
for your
also disagree with he's evaluating.
Okay, cool. We're back to this. Basically, we've gone on this
for far too long, but it goes to show you, right? Like
>> he's doing you a favor. Yeah, basically that's Destin
sucks. That's what I'm trying to say is like basically are you
are you only annoyed with
with the way he said this? Like basically he could have come
up he could have said you said this cuz you like had a hypoxic
brain injury, right? He could have said it for that reason. Well,
actually Auggie's arguing this because he had a hypoxic brain
injury and he's lost most of his cognitive function. He could
have said that, but like do you actually disagree with the way
he's evaluating how this was post talk rationalized? That's more
what I'd want to know. Anyway, let's continue on with stuff cuz
I I've heard that. Listen, I also need to chill, guys. I think
we're like five subs, maybe four subs. Hold on. Maybe four subs
away from another Maybe four subs away from another one.
Let me see here. Let me see here.
I say four. [__] I'm not even looking at the right
thing. God, distracted. Okay. No,
no. Probably five subs from another hour on the stream right
now. Five subs from another hour on the stream. Add the subs.
Okay. Add the subs. Donate. I appreciate everything you guys
do for me. Okay. Cuz I'm probably going to I want to go all the
way through to the actual Ogre boy conversation. How long does
he go on ogre boy for here?
Not that much. >> Even a case where I'm offering a leftwing
critique. a leftwing critique, >> which is to say, you
are spending too much time or not enough time recognizing the
flaws in the rightwing populist space that have charmed you,
Jank, and you're making unsupportable attacks, not just the Democratic
leadership, not just where it matters, but where it's not justified
and even attacking progressives. And so for me saying, hey, hey,
you push, remember this prediction you made where you said we'll
check in in a year. Well, now's a good time as any. You haven't
responded yet. We would like to see some sort of contrition,
some sort of acknowledgement. I would say I don't agree with
Ogre Boy's first comment.
I I also don't know why Ogre Boy It seems like a weird thing
to disagree on. I think it's fine for Pisc to say, "Hey, you
you said that you'd you'd come out and apologize. You come out
and say, >> "Hey, I was wrong. >> Hey, check me guys,
and if in a year we haven't gotten there, if if they have failed
to live up to their end of the bargain, then go ahead and call
me out. I want you to come back and hold me accountable." And
then people do it. And yeah, be mad, right?
>> Left wing,
>> it's condemn. It's like find any way to justify condemns.
Even when you're responding to someone who is fine criticizing
Dems from a leftwing perspective on someone who's defending the
right-wing populist space that's supporting the war and it's
all projection. It's all projection like what like because people
have come to you and be like, did you vote for Kala? Makes you
feel bad. And so anytime when supported Kamla, endorsed Kamla,
said go vote for Kamla, but because it kind of feels similar,
right? accountability feels similar in the election context because
there's a kind of connection factually to the election, right?
There's that connection. It reminds him of how many people made
him feel bad about how he voted in the 2024 election. And so
there's a common cause here, right? They're fellow travelers
because there's accountability, right? There's accountability
and that doesn't feel cuz it reminds him emotionally about how
people made him feel about the >> Well, we we aren't at
the debate yet. We're like trying to get there. I'm trying to
see what the old context was. My thought >> was something
along the lines of Matt NLT, thank you for the other four. >> We
got it. We are there. We've got another hour. Let's go. Thank
you so much, Matt. I appreciate this is
>> Wait, you think Pisco is starking or you think I'm not
starking? Maybe Pisco is snarking. I'm not snarking. I would
>> listen. I personally like Ogre Boy, but this kind of
is
don't lie about me. Don't lie about my positions. Provable intentional
falsehoods. Unless you say, "Actually, I just I didn't really
watch your thing. I didn't really pay attention or I forgot."
I mean, if you want to say that, then I guess I would say it's
not a lie. But until you show otherwise, these are lies. >> Don't
need it. We don't need it. So, I should just go to whatever the
debate is that's on right now.
Hold on. When does it start
about Zog? Dude, I had a I had an awesome rant about Zog just
a little while ago. Okay.
Feel like I'm
feel like Wait, what?
>> Democrats who >> I feel like I am the greatest
Zog poster. Okay, I'm the strongest Zog poster right now. >> Important
to distinguish friend from enemy. And the enemies right now that
he currently is trying to bolster as friends are people >> the
the the establish listen I've already said moment >> sorry
liked and retweeted it >> what you're saying is what's
>> to play games with the war power who he never had any
what he's doing the typical to be found I
>> what then will change your mind you feel uncomfortable
being pressed on the 2022 Iran doesn't you don't >> sorry
the [__] I feel like I feel like Okay, I'm going
to describe a dynamic that's happening. By the way, Pisco wants
to be friends with certain socialists. Okay, one of whom may
be in chat right now. And the price he has to pay is basically
like crucifying Ogre Boy whenever Ogre Boy enters his chat or
the stream. Okay. To to leave Straight Raid as a mod in his Discord,
he actually has to flay Ogre Boy alive. These are the prices.
This is the price he has to pay. Okay. Did anyone else get that
impression? I get that impression >> multiple times. What
caused change position? You're you're shifting. You had a position
and you changed it, >> Was that wrong to do? >> No,
because
>> he's so aggressive, man. >> So if
hold on, he's been on here forever. What the hell? >> Trump
shill and just have no power whatsoever and be pathetic. The
postTrump era.
And I I love that. >> Definitely not there yet. Definitely
not there yet. Definitely not there. There we go. There's ogre
boy. >> It That's the one. Okay, cool.
>> Hold on. >> Hold on. Oh, I got to hear the Hold
on. I got to hear this. What is this? No chance Pisco opens a
Hassan related tweet or anything. Okay. Unless it's to on it.
Pisco would not risk it. He wouldn't ris he couldn't possibly
risk it. Okay.
>> Outcome for 2028. Tucker Carlson runs on an anti-Israel
platform and the Democrats put forward a pro liberal Zionist
pro-defending America's military might candidate. Tucker Carlson
wins by Ronald Reagan numbers. The Democratic Party is done.
The next wave of fascism is here. That's what I'm afraid of.
Tucker Carlson versus Gavin Newsome is unlimited Tucker Carlson
victory. Tucker Carlson's like, "You're Israel first. You're
an attack dog. You're a lap dog for Israel. I can't even tell
what your positions are. One day you say Israel's an apartheid,
you get a boss.
>> Oh no, the the Hassan Tucker Carlson >> from all
of the Israel lobbyists. And next day you come out and you say
actually Israel is not an apartheid. Americans need someone who
actually can stand on moral principles. And as a Christian, I
think Jide is unconscionable. What's going on? Uh uh uh you see
Tucker uh uh uh you're being quite anti-Semitic. Uh, no. >> Is
that like an RFK version? >> I love I love I love >> What?
Dude, what is he paying attention?
It was Gavin Newsome. He's doing Gavin Newsome does this Matthew
McConna voice. That's That's Gavin Newsome as Matthew McCassan
[__] as Gavin Newsome as Matthew McConna. Okay, that's
the voice that he was doing right there. Pretty >> I can't
stand what Israel has done to my Jewish friends. What's going
on? Ronald Reagan victory condition. This is why I've been trying
to urge Democrats to take a stronger stance against Israel. You
cannot have a guy like Tucker Carlson lead the conver. >> Oh,
no. He's a great Gavin Newsome. I'm saying that Gavin Newsome
tries to do the Matthew McConna thing. He does that
I just don't know about that.
He he does like that. Okay. It's like the same thingation on
Israel. The Democrats as a national party have to universally
oppose Israel. If you don't do that, a guy like Tucker Carlson,
who has been leading the conversation for normies on the issue
of Israel, will come out and destroy you. >> I think that's
vibes. I don't have any base to believe that uh Gavin Newsome
would lose to Tucker Carlson in a situation like that.
Like he doesn't have base to believe that either, right? Other
than vibes. I mean, maybe that Israel will be the lynchpin issue
for Americans. I'm not sure about that. And I think that needs
to be justified.
I don't know if that was was that what he's getting on. I think
I think he was saying that attacking the the flip-flopping from
Gavin Newsome there would be effective, painting him as a total
establishment chill beyond just being an Israel shill.
I think that was kind of what Hassan was going for there a little
bit. It wasn't just purely the Israel thing. Although that may
have been a may have been like a decent portion of it. Isco sounds
so defeated. He just has to keep doing his little minstrel show
of hating lefties
he doesn't want to do it. Okay. He doesn't want to do it. He
wants to be he wants the puppet strings to be cut, but he kind
of just has to be like, "Bring the next socialist on so I can
yell at >> I do think internally in the primaries it could
be a major issue.
And I don't know that Tucker will be well positioned to
>> That's where you're wrong. Pisco loves yelling at socialist.
Yeah, I know. >> Do well. Maybe he will. >> I don't
put it. I don't say that it's impossible, but not sure. >> He's
actually overjoyed at the idea Ogre Boy will come on and he could
just unload on this guy, take his day out on Ogre Boy like an
abusive husband coming home and Ogre Boy burned the casserole.
Stupid ball.
Yeah. No, I know. I I get it. I
>> Um, okay. Do we have Ogre boy back? Ogre, do you want
to defend it? Defend it, Ogre. Not this. We need to bury the
hatchet because this is this is a >> I just actually hurt
my hand punching my own hand.
>> I look, I just get angry at what you
Yeah. Jesus. Ow, it hurts. [__] I wanted to make
it loud enough for you guys. I should have just focused more
on
No, you could tell a punch versus a clap. Okay. Okay.
What you did?
Look what you did to him. That's from uh Friday the 13th. You're
not in Discord anymore. You can just call me, right? >> Uh
I think I think Shay might hop on. Just give me two seconds.
I'll be right back. I'm just going to grab some more >> Just
call me cuz I don't think there's any problem with what I did.
I don't think it's a problem. And guys, uh, please don't be no
personal attacks if he does. We'll just keep it on the issues.
Oh, here we go. One sec. Yo, what up, boss? >> Can you
hear me? All right, bro. We need to We need to talk. >> Do
we know? >> Yeah, bro. >> Go to the top of the thread.
Go to the very top. Bear in mind, I'm lagging a little behind
you because I'm watching the stream.
You are responding to Jenk. Jenk is complaining about where are
the Democrats? Where are the Democrats? much in the same way
of that reaction that you did I think Saturday night, right?
you're coming at it from the perspective of you're wanting to
like this is again before we start lawyering, I'm going to give
you how I'm looking at this. So, this isn't this isn't where
you turn around and go that is not what I said or anything like
that. I'm just saying this is how I saw what was in front of
me at the time. So, you're coming at it from the perspective
that you're wanting to rub his nose in his face for the he did
on stage with like Charlie Kirk and like that. And to a degree,
I think that's fair. I think his his
No, this is about the substantive idea that that I need to admit
that he was wrong, that you could trust MAGA ever, that you could
trust the we're not in the populous woods. It's about the populist
woods. Not about Charlie Kirk at all. Charlie K that's just a
straw man. He was brain broken and he wanted to try to like do
something different or do something weird or outside the box
after the election. But the he >> By the way, this is all
I like Pisco. This is all literally just banter, okay? I'm not
seriously like attacking Pisco for being the level of precisely
doing kissy poos with Charlie Kirk on stage. Like that was that
was any sort of like bridging gaps or building coalitions or
whatever the went out the window as soon as like as soon as he
did all that. That was that was just
um but when I'm looking at this the stuff that he's saying if
there was like >> I had two different Hassan laughs dude
I'm that was actually on point for I I haven't done that >> like
politico and [__] there were
>> more than a handful of dems that were coming out and
saying that they were going to fund the uh the emergency funding
bill that they're like it nothing's off the table we'll definitely
consider it blah blah blah. So looking at this, I'm like, but
come on. Like I'm I'm looking at it more along the lines of like
all the anti-comla stuff that he was saying he came up with after
she lost.
like he's he's right now in the moment he's complaining that
there are a lot of Democrats willing to fund Trump's war
or or trying to just go through this like process jargon of like
just come down and make your case and then we can get on board
and and you're trying to bring up like 2024
in in his replies and that's what started why I was saying what
I was
>> So I I view that a lot of things you said as
>> yo how's it going? So, you're not criticizing him for
being precise, but uh I will because uh >> Well, hold on.
>> I just mean I'm not like I'm not like angry about I'm
just like I'm just chilling. Okay. >> Even chill. We're
just being chill. >> I've given him for this. I think that
there are times where he will move the conversation or debate
to a semantic one. I don't know if he I don't think he intentionally
does this. It's sort of just his
like preferred kind of analytical register. Also, Socratic method
lends itself to like these sorts of rabbit holes, but linguistic
precision is not the same thing as genuine understanding. Nor
is it I think sometimes I like it appears that way to people
that that's what's happening. Like, oh, I'm just trying to understand
you. And I do think given that I've like I used to think that
he was doing this in bad faith to like get away from the argument,
but I've I've debated enough to know that like no, I think that
really is just how he tries to understand people. But then it
just seems like it's not really a substantive conversation. It
just turns into this. If what you mean by this word, then by
definition, according to prop logic, then that's true, right?
>> And it just becomes about like dunking on somebody.
>> That's um that's
I did get on him for that earlier tonight. That's not what I'm
talking about. I think when he's trying to be prec precise about
um like you're avoiding the substance of what I'm saying, then
I'm fine with him being precise. when he is like at one point
he drills down on some little throw. Oh, the the ogre boy comment.
He he does like 60 seconds of concern of like just getting angry
about Ogre boy saying >> trolling
concern trolling. >> Well, when when
I a little bit when when Ogre Boy says like, "Oh, Chen came up
with this after Kamalo lost in 2024." And he goes on like a rant
for like 70 seconds, 80 seconds. It's like about it being irrelevant.
And I'm like, "Yeah, it is irrelevant. Just treat it like it's
irrelevant. It was like an irrelevant throwaway comment. That
doesn't matter. >> There was a point where I said like
>> I said, "It's crazy work that Pisco just asked Ogre
Boy a question. He started to answer and then he interrupted
him to get mad at him over something so small." >> Oh,
wait. Did that happen tonight? >> Yeah, it did. It did.
>> Okay. Well, >> as like
we're going to get more of that.
>> Totally disjointed and not at all relevant. And I'm
happy to explain why. So, the first aspect of it like, oh, you're
relitigating 2024. No, I'm not. I'm explicitly not. I'm >> So,
why are you mentioning where's the right-wing populist base?
He's complaining about politicians and
>> and you're bringing up the idea of like where are the
the the the voters that are supposed to be backing you when this
is something that Trump's doing by >> It's not about 2024.
Ogre boy, I need you to acknowledge this. It's about Jinx produ.
It's about Jen's uh sorry ore Jenks predictions
about the future about 2025 2026. That's why when we show the
video he's saying we'll come back in a year if it's really going
to be the case that the rightwing populist base is going to pressure
Trump to cut Pentagon funding to do no wars to not cut Medicaid
and to not be corrupt. So this is not about relitigating
the 2024 election. I need you to acknowledge that because of
course Jenk supported Kamla in the election. Jenk was advocating
for people to so so your claim that I'm trying to relitigate
>> Jenk did the damn thing.
Jen has literally no chance of becoming president was not born
in this country and was actually so committed to getting Biden
off the ticket because he was saying he was too old and there
should have been a proper primary that you can't say the dude
didn't put his money where his mouth is and get and actually
tried to [__] do something even if it was like not
going to work. Yeah. >> Same with the Justice Democrats.
He and Kyle Kolinsky always get to uh like Jenk gets I think
honestly I think so much of Jenk's criticism and heat for the
Justice Democrats comes from the fact that he is the reason that
they're in Congress. like a huge [__] reason that
the squad is in Congress. Ilhan Omar, Rashidita Talib, AOC, like
their races were only possible because of Justice Dems and they
were elected for a very specific reason, but because our system
forces so much compromise and so much moderation that it literally
is not really, it should not be understood like solely as a personal
failure of these politicians, these progressive politicians once
they get into office that they change so much because you really
can't get anything done when you're the one progressive and you
don't build coalitions like it forces moderation. It forces compromise
which makes all of the people that got you into office um which
a ton of them again that supported and like put money into justice
stems to support those races. They weren't even from her state
or her district. So it there's a s I think a deep sense of betrayal
that Jenk like continues to come back to come back to come back
to and why he like holds her to a standard he holds not just
like no other politician to but like no no no Republican or Democrat
like no commentator no one like he puts them in the class of
their own which I think is unfair but I think that's where the
animosity comes from. >> Okay. Um that makes a lot of sense.
I didn't get the impression that he like was overly critical
to be honest with you, but I don't watch a ton of Jenk and I
usually just watch his stuff on
>> he was being overly critical like he said he was like
where are the Democrats? How are AOC how is AOC and the Dems
being outflanked by Tucker Carlson on being outspoken about Iran
and like kind of drawing these sorts of like false equivalencies
when she's voting appropriately. I don't think that she's she's
not being as outspoken as she could be, but and you can criticize
her for that, but I don't think it's necessary or correct to
say that like Tucker Carlson's doing a better job than you, Sweaty.
>> I mean, Tucker Carlson is doing a better job than a
lot of people, but I think that's because the support in his
party is just like you said, like you have to build you have
to build coalitions when you are
like the more progressive person in his party. He that is like
bordering on becoming like a plurality position. this like anti-Israel
position like there are a lot of people who are moving in that
direction. Now, I know I think I >> Wait, when you say
do you mean the voters or do you mean the politicians? >> I
am No, no, no. Hold on. What I'm trying to say is is I think
he sees I don't even know if he's really eyeing 2028 to be honest
with you. I think he could be eyeing like 2032. I think >> the
last thing these people want is actual responsibility and power.
He loves being like, okay, you know the contra meme of like they
just want to endlessly critique. Okay, that's Tucker Carlson.
I actually think that that applies to him. >> But that
was Trump, too. And then he accidentally won.
>> But Trump had been flirting with running for president
>> for years. And he had like started to talk about like
running with the Reform Party and Pat Buchanan like for years
and years and years. Like I don't know that Tucker, this is a
very recent thing for from Tucker Carlson. And I see other people
like Anaka Sparian trying to like wish cast it into existence.
I don't really see Tucker Carlson himself saying that he's going
to. And just because he's not saying that he is doesn't mean
that he's not intending to. But >> Cruz comment
>> um Ted Cruz comment >> that he said who is he
talking to now? >> I can't remember who he's talking to.
Oh, Piers. He's talking to Piers Morgan and he said he was talking
about Ted Cruz and Ted Cruz said he was going to like run in
2028 just to debate Tucker Carlson or something and he's like,
"Yeah, now I do feel like running just to just to go debate Ted
Cruz again because it went so well for me last
I saw a tweet earlier
>> that was reposted by Undemonia and replied to by Shuan
Head. They're married and they're both Catholic. >> And
uh he was like this is just like an anti-atholic screed that
Ted Cruz has posted and I' I've bookmarked it but I haven't looked
into it cuz as a former as a lapsed Catholic myself, I will be
the judge of that as to whether or not it's actually anti-atholic
cuz uh there is some anti-atholic bias. Sure. It's not nearly
to the extent that Catholics like to pretend that it is, but
it does exist still somewhat.
>> How much of that do you think is I'm starting to wonder
how much of that is like
explicitly like possibly from a Zionist lens. I don't want to
like introduce that into everything, but I didn't realize how
much like there's like sort of some some maybe it's just not
an inherently like built-in appreciation for Zionism and like
the state of Israel and Catholicism that I do think like gets
some people to really >> I don't know people don't [__]
with it as much. >> Oh, it's not there. It's a to it's
a Protestant thing. Yeah. Like Cathol like Joe Biden even though
he's he's a Christian but he's a Catholic. So him being a fanatical
Zionist has like nothing to do with his religion.
Well, fanat you say fanatical Zionist. Okay, this is
>> a committed Zionist because fanatical kind of conjurers
up like a religious thing, but that's not what I mean. >> Well,
all I all I can say about Joe Biden. I say this in my chat all
the >> Show me the picture of him touching the wall, kissing
the wall. You can't do it. Okay.
Joe Joe did somehow Joe Biden was able to save off a war with
Iran despite a maximal pressure campaign. Way bigger pressure
than Donald Trump was under right after October 7th, I feel like.
I don't know, I I do think the the Catholicism has like something
to do with it a little bit. Like the the lack of like a religious
teaching that you should have some reverence for this place or
reverence for the people and stuff. I don't know. >> Wait,
you mean lack of the lack of it?
>> Yeah, like just basically not having that thing built
in. >> Oh, yeah. Like Biden is like total American chauvinism.
Like Biden is actually like America first. I really do think
that Democrats to the extent that like there is a like you could
come up with a coherent America first movement. It really is
the Democrats in my opinion. This is why you see like uh some
of the Democrats being willing to go along with this and then
leadership like they clearly are okay with this like Hakeem Jeff
and and Chuck Schumer. Um and I think that's partially a function
of like their Apac money, but I also think it's just partially
like a function of their ideology and what they believe is going
to maintain like American dominance and supremacy and hegemony
and all the big words. If Joe Biden hadn't undone the shutdown
of the border, I do believe that you could argue he was a better
MAGA president than Donald Trump in his first term. >> Oh
yeah, for sure. For sure. like
they're smart to not co-opt that movement, but like yeah, they're
actually committed to America for like again the fact that like
>> like there are criticisms that are being levied at Trump
for being isolationist like AOC AOC is going to this Munich conference
and she's saying that Trump is like like there's a rhetorical
suggestion I don't think this is the substant substantive point
she was trying to make that he is isolating us from the rest
of the and he's like not engaging in uh like enough action abroad
basically and like crit and kind of framing like the pull certain
moves that he's making as being isolationist
um when he is literally the most neo like he is easily outclassing.
He's making George Bush and Dick Cheney blush man as far as like
the intervention that this guy has done um in these two terms.
So there's this kind of weird double speak going on that because
he's pulling back like he's like openly criticizing NATO. They
got rid of USAD. Like they're cutting off like soft power. They're
like pulling out of the JCPOA and like ruining trade agreements
and it's making these countries like flock to other superpowers
like China. Um, yes, that is having that sort of effect, but
Trump is still absolutely like very interventionist. And the
Democrats are criticizing him for not being interventionist enough,
like for extinguishing these avenues of soft power
and for like relinquishing these different modes that we had
um to maintain diplomatic ties with allies and >> Sure.
I mean, is that you kind of do you characterize NATO as an interventionist?
I mean, I don't necessarily Yeah, I don't necessarily like think
No, I just don't think of it that way. It's weird to hear it
characterized that way. >> Yeah, I do. It's like it's liberal
hawkishness. You know, you can make the argument that it it should
be, but I do think that it is interventionist. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Fair enough. Hold on. Someone in my chat just said
it it No, it definitely is interventionist. I just don't think
of it that way because it's like a status quo thing. So, I think
of intervention more as in acute terms, I guess. So that would
be >> well that's how Democrats get away with this criticism
being framed the way that it is of Donald Trump.
um trying to say like he's he's isolated like he's an isolationist
or whatever because it is understood as just sort of maintaining
the current global order like having all of these top like um
like the NATO and all these existing things like the existing
status quo did favor the United States as the global superpower
but we're moving towards a multipolar world so that's not now
to to push for that in light of that multipolarity emerging you
are now pushing to maintain American dominance and supremacy
would You could argue, you
>> the thing is is like
the the reason why that's happening like and our standing on
the global stage is not totally ruined after Bush takes undertakes
the Iraq war and the Afghanistan war is because he goes through
the work of actually propagandizing the country and the world
and having a pretext of WMDs.
He had national support there liked
>> media support the backdrop of 911. all of that, but
it's a disaster. And yet, it's not entirely discrediting to him.
Not only because he's not held to account, but Obama decides
not to hold him to account for that. The American public has
since kind of rehabilitated George Bush and the admin because
they see like oh okay like neocon hawkishness from the b like
the Bush era was at least competent versus what you see here
which is just totally reckless and aimless and like goals change
or non-existent
and it's an admin populated literally with sickopants and people
that don't know anything. It's it's like podcasters it's grifters
like RFK Jr. It's people like Tulsi Gabbard that are and Christy
Nome and Pam Bondi just they're there because they're loyalists
because Trump had so many people flip in the first admin because
he tried to run it kind of closer to how a typical Republican
admin would be which is like again you're filled with neocons
but those neocons actually know things and will tell you to govern
a certain way and if you don't they all resigned or he got he
fired them and got rid of them when they wouldn't tell him what
he wanted. And so with this admin, he's not making that mistake,
but you're getting these sorts of outcomes because it's like
interfering and disrupting the bureaucracy that actually gets
the logistics of these things and the intelligence correct.
>> Yeah, I would say that they know they they've been a
part of the sessions like all of the neocon the long-term neocon
politicians be a part of all the sessions explaining exactly
how and why you can't go and just invade Iran. >> Yeah.
They get rid of all the people with any amount of of schooling
in that and they're like, "Yeah, let's go." It's >> and
it's not cuz they're like liberal. It's like, "No, they want
to do this. Schumer wants to do this. Keem Jeff wants to do they
want you to do it competently, though. And they know that this
admin's not going to do it competently." I >> mean, to
say the least. I
>> But that's what happens when like you have It's like
Stalin.
Like Stalin refused to would get rid of people around him that
did not tell him what he wanted to hear that would not manufacture
his own reality. Trump is doing the same thing like he is this
admin is just he gets rid of anybody who just doesn't reaffirm
what he wants to hear and he listens to TV >> kind of just
every strongman leader right I I believe she is doing that right
now believe she has done over the past like two or three years
she's done like multiple purges of his military no >> under
the guise of corruption
>> as far as I know >> very very corrupt people yes
um yeah >> but the that's the difference though like in
China they're big like anti-corruption thing some of it baseless,
some of it not, or like some of it like highly politically motivated
or personally motivated. They actually like, you know, skulls
were cracked. Like people ended up in jail and like were held
to account in a court of law, even if it was sort of a kangaroo
court. It's not the same thing here. Like you you up here and
you just get fired. That's it.
Like it's not like you actually face a significant penalty. If
anything, like you're likely to get a pardon later if you do
if they do try to get you in trouble for anything. I think they're
going to >> I I
really hope that they just figure out a way to um I I think Pisco's
mentioned it that the section 3 of the 14th amendment, you could
possibly apply that in reverse and say potentially that Trump
is always been an illegitimate president, so his pardons are
ineffective. I hope they figure out something that >> cuz
at this point is going to say absolutely [__] not
that he and and said this is a long shot. >> Yeah. Yeah.
But Pete Hexith is going to get pardoned for sure. And >> all
of them are >> after after he did away with the civilian
like um like collateral damage prevention team and then they
bomb a school. I just feel like at that point it's like oh >> this
guy literally like >> he heard a bunch of little girls
to own the libs and I'm like done with I think mistakes going
to jail for that is the minimum the minimum penalty at this point.
It's actually me. >> I mean, in a just world, he'd be tried
at the HG or dragged in front of the ICC, but we're not signitories
to the ICC, so that's not happening. And he's not getting tried
at the HEG. He's going to be preemptively pardoned by Trump.
>> Pardons could be solved with the promise of a future
pardon. I don't even know what that means. >> How do you
mean?
>> I'm sorry. I was reading chat message. >> No,
no, no. I'm like asking that chatter like what do you mean? We
need a constitutional amendment to overturn the ruling or um
like a new Supreme Court, a court to be expanded and then they
overturn it with another case that makes its way up and challenges
it. >> Missy Elliott said, "Can you ask Aaron if she thinks
stronger deterrence is needed for powerful people?"
No question.
>> Is water wet? Um yeah, >> as opposed to regular
criminals. As opposed to regular >> You're talking to a
communist talking to somebody who doesn't even think private
property like people can be trusted with private property and
not abuse it. No, clearly I think this >> Asmin tweet.
Wait, new Asmin tweet or the the video.
>> Why is pardoning a thing? I don't know.
>> What are we looking at?
>> We're looking at a monarch monarchist propaganda from
As >> you sent me the other day. This is more of that.
>> Um, wait, no. I just sent you Hassan
>> calling him Asminy, which I thought was hilarious. I
I think it's hilarious. Personally, I'm I'm more angry that So,
wait, did you see Did you see this Wall Street Journal article
that um basically a bunch of people in the Jerusalem
>> some Jerusalem office Oh, you know what I'm talking
about then with >> Oh, wait, wait, wait. Continue, continue,
keep going. >> Okay. The the >> there's a cable in
the Oh, was it the Jerusalem embassy? Basically, Israel saying
that listen um the regime has not cracked. If there's a revolt
or an uprising of any kind, it will be brutally
like they will be slaughtered.
Also, we're going to continue pushing for them to have a revolt.
It's like unironically. And then BB was just saying today after
they killed Larijani
a different Solmani who's the head of one of the generals or
high up in the >> they killed these two guys and they're
like, "You guys should go out and celebrate now." >> It's
just like, dude, what are you >> Like I I unironically
think they're trying to bait people into getting slaughtered
so they have more of a pretext to continue strikes and continue
the war. >> Um, it's transparently so >> they need
something to do. I thought you were talking about this uh Wall
Street Journal article, but there's been a couple more since
then. This one came out. This one was on Saturday. Trump knew
the risk of Iran blocking the straight of war moves. He still
went to >> Oh, yeah. I've covered this. Yeah. No, even
even I think um Dan Kaine came out and said, "Hey, no, I did
I did talk about this at some point in some press conference."
He's like basically like, "Hey, yeah, no, I I definitely told
you about this
>> told you about it."
Um did you see the John Bolton tweet? >> No, it's a John
Bolton tweet. I shouldn't be smiling. >> John Bolton with
the
maximum interventionalist W. Okay. In 2018 2019 I made the case
for regime change in Iran as often as I could. Voices in Trump's
orbit often cited Iran's capacity to close the straight of Hormuz
as the reason against regime change. Trump has been fully aware
of this is that this is a possibility and yet he did not prepare.
>> Friends like this, man. Just kidding. They're not friends.
But
I mean >> like this. >> Trump is also like demented.
You could tell him this this morning and he still he's not going
to remember.
Oh, I I literally said, dude, people keep getting mad at me because
I say it's like Israel's war and Israel has to own this war.
And I think Pisco is even getting mad about that. >> Yeah.
He's like, "Don't let Ma off the hook for that." But it's like,
dude,
>> an like obviously it is both. It is both of these things.
>> Yeah. The analogy I'm going with is if I have a family
member who's dying of cancer and some swindler comes along and
takes all their money because they're like desperate for anything
to help. Uh I'm going to blame the swindler. I'm going to be
very focused on the swindler. The family member shouldn't be
making decisions. Okay? And we could deal with that. But there
is one morally bankrupt character here who is willing to put
their interests ahead of any other human beings. And that's the
person I'm going to focus on. That also technically applies to
Trump. I'm It's like there's only one person benefiting from
this situation and so to say it's like oh no it's all on Trump.
It's like okay well it's all on Trump that he's sacrificing American
security, financial wealth, everything
for Israel's security and wealth. I think the reason why >> look
at it that way >> are because what you're saying I think
is largely true and definitely a fabulous narrative to like uh
message to voters honestly but they're uncomfortable with it
by they I mean like you know critics like peace go because it's
like what am I supposed to do with that you know we if that's
true and this country is run is zog controlled or whatever I
can't do anything about that >> no it's not controlled
though you can do everything about it >> can't it can't
be the I know, but they think that that's what you're saying
when you make that criticism.
>> I know. And I lost my mind about that earlier. Okay.
It's not. I'm not saying no, you can vote. You can vote. Vote
every single
I was going to say I'll just say Zogbot. Vote every single Zogbot
out. Okay. Every single one. Get them all out. Which I like I'm
on the same page with Pisco. I just think I think it's better
to speak about it this way and to stop like letting other people's
neurosis and insecurities go. >> But people see the thing
is to vote them out people have to know who's who and they have
to have the information to be able to vote them out. But this
administration is incre is is trying to make it difficult for
you to know what reality is, what they're actually doing, what
is going on. They're trying to they're talking and flirting about
with punishing and sanctioning news stations that just accurately
report and don't report the war in a patriotic way as Hexus says.
Um,
and Apac has now they know that they're poison, right? And so
they're an organization that takes a bunch of MAGA and right-wing
money and they funnel it into Democrat races or primaries specifically.
You saw this today. So, Katabukaza lost her uh lost to Daniel
Bliss or Bliss
for the Dem nomination for that congressional seat. They put
millions into it, but they weren't funding a bunch of ads attacking
cat. Towards the end, they started funding progressive ads for
a progressive candidate that was splitting the vote who wouldn't
drop out. Who even went out of her way to say, "I don't co-sign
or endorse. I know. I disavow that Apac is creating these ads.
I They're not from me. They're not. I feel like they're not.
They're just making them and they're >> fine, is it?
>> That's not fine, is it? >> Well, it shouldn't
be, but it is. According to Citizens United, it is. So, what
you're talking about can't happen until there's a constitutional
amendment to overturn the candidate. The candidate fine. She's
not the She was literally their preferred candidate, right? >> Laura
Fine. Um, >> you're not talking about Laura Fine right
now. You talk about a different >> No, I'm talking about
uh Daniel. Daniel, what's his name is the prefer I thought was
Daniel Bis was the preferred candidate. I thought >> Daniel
Bis and Laura Fine were the two they were supporting, but Daniel
Bis has apparently got some other issues.
DSA candidate Bush. Okay. Okay. Got it. >> Then it's a
boutique issue because then it's like it's not a question of
like is he pro- Israel or not. It's like no, he's not pro-Israel
enough then. >> Yeah. I think he's had some comments that
are like not perfect for them.
>> Yeah. Biz was J Street. Okay. Okay. Uh tweet doesn't
travel well. I mean, doesn't it though? I'll be honest. I would
expect I would expect Cat to struggle just in that she's like
a young I unfortunately this is just facts you have to deal with.
A lot of people are still bigoted, especially voters. Okay.
>> They see like a young woman on the ballot. They're just
not going to vote for them. I'm sorry. That's just the way it
is. >> Was saying this yet again. I found a video of him
saying that like he's just straight up saying except for Palestine
her foreign policy is terrible and it's because she's a young
woman like just up on that. >> I'm sorry. I'm not I'm not
saying it's because she I'm literally just saying that people
will literally see her like her face and they'll be like, "Oh,
>> for sure." No, no, no. For sure. I'm saying that like
if even Hassan who's like this, you know, male feminist lefty
or whatever, that's how he's perceived anyway. That's I think
>> that he's even got some >> if he's leaning into
that or whatever like where he's like finding disagreement like
if that's the first thing that he's reaching for to explain it
then I know that's certainly the impression of normies.
>> Yeah, I did find it a little offputting when I was watching
Hassan and he was like just looking at the pictures of Cat Abigazel
and saying like well
I'm sorry. I'm going to do a bit here that I don't want to do
with you on screen and me not. Sorry. Sorry. Never mind. I'm
backing out. I'm backing out immediately. I'm backing out >> Do
it. No, you have to commit. Do it.
I It's just a Hana bit.
>> So that's not If it's just that then just do it. >> Uh
hold on, hold on, hold on. Where's the tweet? It's like It's
like this. He's like, "God, why won't she just do this instead
of talking about China? Why can't she just be this person? Just
sit there and look like that instead of talking about China."
It was something along these lines. Okay, that's the kind of
thing Hassan was was doing. It's really I just thought it was
inappropriate personally.
Yeah. I just thought it was inappropriate of him to consistently
pull up her pictures like this. >> Would you say she's
a thought? >> She be like, "Why?" Unrelated, but not not
what I was saying at all. Not what I was saying.
>> Really not.
>> Oh. Anyway, she um
she This is pretty good for like a first run when you're under
30, which I believe she is. I think she's like 28 27 or something,
>> She's like my age. Yeah. She's like 26
>> Yeah. like a first run and
I people are like, "Oh, this doesn't travel well." It's like,
"Dude,
how much what was the spending for and against,
right?
Like you could and people do this all the time." Oh, listen,
it it just doesn't work. And it's like, hey, I think there are
some people who are pretty invested in her not working in in
basically fermenting this narrative. >> Yeah. I love how
they act like again there's plenty of appetite for progressivism,
etc. Can you scroll up a >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yep. >> Within
the de Thank you. the Democratic electorate. But the very online
version of it doesn't travel really well. Doesn't really travel
well. Says guy who like again the things that these types like
the Nate Silver types >> do is also extremely online politics.
As if complaining about Mandani not disavowing globaliz
also extremely online politics. I'm not saying that Nate Silver
did that, but like those adjacent to him will will have those
sorts of grievances for campaigns. And they will not just have
the grievance, they'll also say if they don't change, this could
tank their chances. So they're saying that like the online narratives
or whatever like translate into real world problems for them.
But you're looking at like Graham Plat like, okay, so Janet Mills
is still trying to secure the uh
like be the primary Democrat Democrat candidate to challenge
Susan Collins in Maine. and her attack ads against Platner. You
know what? She's starting with his comments about like women
wanting to be uh arted. Not actually
uh >> Wait, he's got those too.
>> No wonder Chank loves >> Yeah, there's worse on
that Reddit, man. That made me like stop defending him.
>> Oh, I didn't even know about that. Wait, it got worse
than uh I just wanted to go kill people. That's why I signed
up for the mil. It got worse than that. >> Oh, that's what
I was talking about. That to me that that was a comment where
I was like this dude's a psychopath. Never mind. >> Sorry.
I thought I thought we were talking about comments on like that
that >> No, he basic he said women need to take responsibility
for the role they play in getting like assaulted or raped like
they were drunk or something like that. Um he's like since apologized
for it. Um
>> he also made comments about how like Indians don't tip
or something like that. She's not hit him with that one yet.
Uh, but the fact that they're starting with those attack ads
instead of the Nazi tattoo, which is had far more like internet
traffic and discourse dedicated to that when that dropped tells
me that like, you know, Nate Silver would be the type to be like,
"Oh, he can't win in the general cuz Nazi tattoo, right?" Well,
Janet Mills has got DC consultants that are just like Nate Silver
surrounded that she's surrounded by. They're looking at the same
information, if not more, and they're coming to the conclusion
that no, this isn't the first way that we should attack him,
>> which honestly I'm so I agree with like the analysis
in terms of online versus uh real life that Nate's sort of missing
in the same way, but I'm just more shocked that it's not
I'm just more shocked that it's like
that that wouldn't be the thing you attack with the little Nazi
tattoo. >> Why? I >> you just said that like the
you think the Zog stuff is like you know fertile
>> I sorry the Zog stuff is fertile ground because Israel
has a tangible effect and you're objectively doing something
that is at the detriment of your country for the benefit of Israel.
>> Yes, but you can definitely sell this to people via
anti-semitism instead of anti-ionism. They're going to be way
more willing to embrace that. >> Not that level of anti-semitism
doesn't work yet. It straight up doesn't the >> but he
doesn't have a swastika tattoo. >> It's not a swastika.
It's it's a toten cough or whatever.
>> So your claim that I'm trying to relitigate the 2024
election is wrong, isn't it? >> Hit show more. >> It's
wrong, isn't it? Isn't it wrong? Wait, isn't it wrong? I'm not
relitigating 2024. You're projecting that. You're projecting
that cuz that's what I would do with you. >> Hit show more.
>> No. No. This first comment, this first >> I'm
talking about my first comment. What I'm saying, you're talking
to me right now. I'm not trying to relitigate 2024. Jake and
I were in the same
what? Why does Peace go so scared to hit show more right now?
Why wouldn't he just hit show more?
>> That shouldn't be scary for him to hit show more
>> in 2024. >> You're mentioning 2024 in the damn
tweet. Just because 2024 election is
doesn't mean that I'm litigating who was preferable to win. I'm
talking about his predictions
in the future after the election was over. I'm not trying >> what
I understand like relitigating 2024 to mean. I think that's a
broad enough
um I didn't even I have like literally even though I just watched
it most of that debate I had not even bothered to read the exchange
that they had on Twitter and apparently um I had stopped into
Pisco stream a couple of nights ago and like for hours he like
like at probably two hours is what it seemed like it was just
him going over the this the tweet exchange and you had pulled
up that stream um this like just go like literally just like
ogre boy starking for whatever reason. then I guess we have nothing
else to do. And uh I still don't if the contention is like why
are you saying that like I can't bring out like I'm relitigating
2024. It's like well you're relitigating like a claim or prediction
that Jenk made in 2024, right? But Fusco is taking it to mean
like who he supported for the election.
But I don't think that's what Ogre Boy was ever saying unless
I'm wrong.
>> I mean I guess we'd have to watch or read the show more
part. So just wait. I'm going to actually
Where is your Where is the right-wing populist base that you
assured us was for real your enemy? You claimed the mainstream
media and donor class was defeated in the 2024 election. You
were in the populous woods. So, this is I I don't think it's
relitigating the election. Uh it's reitigating the outcome after
the election. The sorry, the what you can take away from the
election. Chen come up with all this after Kamala lost. We have an
illegal war of choice. Blah blah blah blah blah blah blah.
I'm So is is Pisco saying that Ogre Boy is accusing him of relitigating
or honestly he's like he's yelling about it right now? >> It's
just it's this Spider-Man meme. It's both of the both of these
people are relitigating 2024 constantly and that's fine. >> I
now that I'm looking at it I don't know why peace go this is
like yeah it's irrelevant to the point of like the substance
of oh you should concede to the fact that these populists didn't
show up for the the issues you said they
is too we okay >> it is possible for somebody to be a complete
and total hypocrite and for their argument now to still be correct
>> and there are points where you can you can literally
I'm not sure um I looked up the etmology of it not that long
ago but there are points in this where I think Ogre boy approaches
saying that to him and you can literally see Pisco's demeanor
shift entirely
I mean like it's Latin He tells on himself so hard because he'll
go from like screaming you, you this, you that to all of a sudden
it's just like the little dog voice and he backs off when he's
like not when he think he knows his opponent has a point or he
doesn't entirely disagree with it or he doesn't know enough.
>> Big dog, little dog that before >> with with
I'm back it up just about. I'm talking about his predictions
in the future after the election was over. I'm not trying to
say anything else
>> with with peace and love. For the love of God, please
hit show more.
>> Well, no. I need you to address that. I'm not trying
to relitigate 2024. >> I'm asking, >> do you agree?
Yes or no?
>> You're still trying to bring up 2024 in the moment when
he's trying to talk about why is funding going for Trump's illegal
war.
I'm trying to raise his predictions post 2024
given a set of realities that he said were real. That is to say
that the donor class and mainstream media was defeated and so
we're in the populist woods and so they're going to reign in
Trump. That's not relitigating 2024. It's relitigating his predictions
after he saw the result of 2024.
>> Do you agree? >> Relitigate. Maybe relitigate
isn't the right word, but you're trying to rehash it. You're
trying to throw it back in his face. >> That's undeniable.
>> Sorry. I I'm trying to
bring to his
>> I I think Ogre agrees with Pisco and Pisco just doesn't
um or or like that's not what Ogre like meant to say. I don't
know if Ogre maybe said like you're taking something. But what
what what the concern is is Pisco is taking something that Cheng
said in the past and being like you need to you need to admit
you were wrong before we can have the rest of the discussion
and he's just like hey maybe we just all pull in the same direction
on the >> it's literally I mean this is it's just like
stop looking in the rearview mirror stop getting cheap dunks
on people he's call he's like angry about the war and you can
criticize the way he's going about criticizing Dems for that
but to bring up like but first you must concede that you were
wrong about this is low hanging fruit and it is a dunk which
you can do but it's clear to me that what Ogre boy is saying
is like like why not just take any alley that you can do they
really have to do like um the sort of public reckoning first
maybe they do
>> well that's sort of like Pisco's whole thing on Twitter
so I kind of understand why Pisco is doing it hey you said >> I
know why he's doing it but then just like you know oh that's
what you're
>> but I don't know that Pisco would deny that you M no,
I don't think you'd deny it either if you say it. But the issue
is Ogre Boy said something like that he disagrees with that needs
to also be relitigated. I just I don't know. I sometimes I think
the way Pisco is like this aggressive. I do think
like it's I there's fault on both sides, but the way he's this
aggressive I think prevents people from just going like, "Oh
yeah, I know I misspoken," which Ochre Boy is doing now, and
actually this is what I meant. >> You're you're telling
me that going, "Yes, sir. No. Yes or no? Define if what you mean
by this is that
logically
>> Are you telling me that makes people close up?
>> I don't know. >> I don't know about that. >> I'd
say just the tone. The tone more than anything. The the yelling
tone.
>> More than the
I'm not talking about the yelling tone. Just ilk. Yes or no?
>> Which he said to do. He said we'll come back in. Look
at what I'm asking. Look at what I'm asking you in the in the
reply. Just hit okay. >> Didn't Jane come up with all this?
So So then you say, "Didn't he come up with all this after Kamla
lost as though I suggested otherwise? How is that responsive?
Do you think that like >> why why would
he not being responsive
>> by Pisco bringing up, hey, you said this thing that
was incorrect or whatever." Literally not responsive to any criticism
that Jenk made. But you can then say that No, but I also I like
made substantive rebuttals against Jenk's stupid points elsewhere,
right? Just not in this tweet. >> which I'm pretty sure
he did cuz he like Yeah, I watched part of his stream the other
day where he was like going through Jenk's video saying that
like the progressives are being outflanked by Tucker Carlson
or whatever.
>> Yeah. And I think what what's funny is is it's like
about the current Twitter conversation and then piece goes very
mad that Ochre Boy is not taking into account the video that
Ochre Boy did >> As as very funny as this conversation
>> moment. Why would you be going back to 2024
when he's trying to talk about that the only way that they would
be able to do this funding is if they get Democrat support. The
only way. And he's trying to say what the [__] is
going on. >> So first of all, >> so you're bringing
up 2024. First of all, first of all, that's not true just as
a whip count that they need Democrats cuz obviously they control
the branches of Congress. >> There's unified party control.
So, what you just said is false just based on the whiff count.
But putting that aside, how is this responsive at all? Didn't
Jane come up with all this after Kamla lost? No [__]
You don't think I know that? You don't think that's what I'm
saying? >> Hold on. Rewind. Pause. Maybe I've been asleep
for like a century or so.
I thought they have they have a filibuster approved majority
in the Senate. >> They don't have a No, but they can use
reconciliation. And they also can't you can't stop the war in
Congress.
>> You can't stop the war in Congress. No, but you can
fight coming up with a [__] uh a funding bill. For
sure. >> You can fight it, but they have reconciliation.
I'm repeating myself. >> You already have
>> Here's the thing that's getting left out of this. Let
me link it to you.
So
Trump announced at the end of February he intended to do this.
Democrats had many days
to prepare a war powers resolution in anticipation of that. They're
doing that right now with Cuba. They're literally preparing to
to launch another uh resolution to reign in Trump. I think this
is being led by Tim Kaine. So if you control F and search and
though
and read the paragraph, you'll see what point I'm trying to arrive
at. And though Jeffre like Schumer, hold on, I need to And though
Jeffre like Schumer vocalized his support for the war powers
resolution in the House, he dragged his feet for eight critical
days before doing so. The New York Times broke the news that
Trump was deploying the largest armada in over 20 years to surround
Iran on February 18th. From that day until February 26th, when
Jeffre and Schumer belatedly signed off on the war powers vote
a week after it was first proposed, neither Jeffre nor Schumer
issued a single press release or social media post about the
pending attack. When they finally did to arrange for votes either
this Monday or Tuesday, the war was long underway and dozens
of Iranian officials, including their head of state, the Ayatollah
Ali K had already been killed.
>> So, they could have
uh like fought or because it was already being reported that
they were anticipating this like and it go the same goes for
like any other Dem or whatever. Like, you know, you could say
the same of Massie or Connor or whatever. you could indict more
people, but just strictly speaking to the this is the minority
leader in the Senate and the minority minority leader in Congress
like knew about this and they did not uh put forth this uh like
tried to push to put this forth until after Trump already took
those
>> Yeah. I mean it's
Yeah, it's obvious that if they really wanted to prevent this,
this is just the point you're making. If they really wanted to
prevent this, they had the entire time it takes like logistically
to move an entire armada to the Middle East. >> From the
Pacific or America or I guess did some
>> and and here's the here's the thing like they don't
even if those four Democrats had not voted the way that they
did because Mosovitz and a few other people flipped um and voted
no to the war powers resolution which meant that they didn't
want to reign in Trump on this even though they could have. uh
they still didn't have the numbers to be able to get that over
the finish line to the Senate. But that means that is a bigger
indictment of Dems to me because it means that you can be safe
because you can't actually be held accountable cuz you're the
minority party. You literally every single those four Dems could
have flipped and they still don't have the numbers. So you can
do you should be saying whatever the [__] you want
because no you can also say when people ask well why aren't you
doing it then? Well because we literally can't but we're sounding
the alarm and we're banging pots and pans and doing what we can
to get the attention of the American public for what's to come
and who to blame and it's not this party cuz we're saying right
now we're looking to it. >> They could have been a lot
of the time. Yeah, sure. >> Yeah. They they don't do that
even though they're literally not expected to do anything cuz
they're the minority party and they still don't make as much
of a you a fuss as they could.
>> I know. And I think that's why it's totally fine. I
don't know about Jeff cuz I don't he hasn't had that long a track
record, but it's like Schumer absolutely wanted Iran to get hit.
Like I'm sorry. Schumer just wanted this war like a thousand%
the whole time. >> He was literally saying give me a reason.
Give me a reason and we can do
but he pretends to be against it. But he Schumer is probably
not seeking re-election. He's an ideologically committed Zionist
and this is what he is going to um you know close his tenure
in the Senate doing
like we ball. This is what I want to do because I'm not seeking
re-election. I don't care how electorally unpopular it is. I
don't care how bad my approval rating is because I'm not seeking
election again. So, and it's my party. Yeah.
awesome. when people I think you should have to I don't know
there's like a sweet spot between 40 and 60 where you should
be a politician and then outside of that sweet spot
out go away like the the administrative years or something people
get >> oh there should definitely be a mandatory retirement
age
>> I I don't even it might be maybe it's 65 but I do think
it's like >> it should be that basically to 65 is where
you should be a politician and then outside of that you should
be out >> repres Clyurn
>> is running for reelection.
That dude was literally born a month after the fall of France.
That is how old he is.
He's like 88 or something. Like 87. >> Once again, we're
seeing an example of Black Don't Crack over here. Okay. This
guy does not look 85 years old. This guy does not look almost
90 years old.
Little older here. No, HE DOESN'T EVEN LOOK THAT OLD, MAN.
That's crazy. That's crazy.
looks like black Bernie Sanders.
No, he doesn't. I >> mean, Bernie doesn't look as old as
he is either. That's
>> But he still had a heart attack in 2020 on the campaign
trail, which is why like that
like at the time I was like, "No, he's like good for his age."
And when that happened, I was like, this is why like there's
it doesn't matter if they seem like, you know, spry for their
[__] age. Doesn't change the fact that you're still
approaching 80 and any day now, you could have a [__]
stroke. You could have a heart attack. You could have
like a widowmaker. Something could happen, you know. >> I
do know. Yeah. No, it's not not reliable people, these geriatric
folks. Okay. Not known for the reliability, not known for their
>> I mean, you can you can rely on them to uh run for reelection.
Not much else. >> Dems coming forward, ranking Dems that
are on like numerous committees. I don't have all like I know
three of the names. I don't know all of them because a lot of
them are >> This is This is going to upset everybody on
the internet. So, we had the uh
we had the Apac thing. While disappointed that Laura Fine did
not prevail, voters rejected two anti-Israel candidates in this
in this race. Cat Abigazella and Bushra Amawala. We were especially
proud to help defeat Abigazela who centered her campaign on attacking
Israel and demonizing pro-Israel Americans. like we were especially
proud to help defeat her in in parenthesis by funding the other
person we just complained about Bushra.
>> And Daniel Bis says cope. He says, "Hey, I'm gonna I'm
gonna fight you guys, too. >> I'm gonna fight you." Hey,
>> but whatever. >> I'm gonna fight you guys, too.
I'mma fight you. I'm gonna fight you guys.
>> Wow. Uh, did we Hold on. Somebody sent me an AP pack
tweet, too. Tonight, six candidates Hold on. Go back to the itself.
Tonight, six candidates built their campaigns on inner undermining
the US Israel relationship and demonizing pro-Israel Americans.
Democratic voters in Illinois rejected all six of these far-left
extreme anti-Israel candidates. Being pro-Israel is good policy
and good politics. Hold on. I need the I need the rabbit picture.
Hold on. This is the only response, I think. Where did I just
put my AP pack tweet? The heck?
No, not not Clyburn, get out. >> Taking too long to
You're losing it. You're losing a moment. You're losing the
n >> losing the window.
Becoming less funny by the second, even when you get it up there.
There we go. >> We're good. We're good.
Only have so much time.
So much time. >> I've never heard of before. When you >> We
have Chank and Anna doing the hands. I don't have Anna doing
the hands. You know the the Chank Larry Ellison thing, right?
Do you mean >> Oh, yeah. I do. Yeah, I do. already have
them coming forward saying that that that article came out before
this
>> when they're
>> that whole from bis being like cope to Apac it's it's
still like a proionist talking point because all they're doing
is like incorporating the necessary disavowels that they need
to to continue being pro-Israel and still within the Democratic
party the same way they go
[__]
uh I don't like the settlements I want a two-state solution like
it's it's just now it's also [__] pack, but not [__]
street, not [__] pro-Israel allies. They will never
say those things. And even if and if they are saying those things,
it's not because they've changed their mind. It's because they
have to say it. It it's now become like a thing that they have
to a virtue signal that they have to say in order to continue
being pro- Israel. >> Yeah. Basically, like if if um
if people didn't need some way to vent about how Israel's acted,
they wouldn't be doing it at all. Yeah, I agree with you. >> Dang,
they're willing to fund it, right? reconciliation at that point.
I'm just dealing with the claim that you need Democrats in or
you said just now in order for this word the supplemental to
be funded, you need Democrat votes. That's not true, is it? >> If
I didn't consider reconciliation, but I don't I >> I think
Ogre Boy is saying now he doesn't believe you could do this through
reconciliation. That reconciliation you have to have some plan
to get the money back, but I don't
>> I would find it farfetched that they're going to burn.
It's irrelevant to me because the argument can still stand that
Democrats are still not doing all that they can even as the minority
party as the minority party to be outspoken against this war.
That is like that can be a self-standing criticism of Democrats.
You can say that in the moment it's not the most productive thing
to make if you or like to point out or say um if you're not
giving way more heat to Republicans because at the end of the
day it is the Trump admin's fault, right? But it's a as a self-standing
criticism, it's valid. And I think probably agrees. >> I
think >> I think the lack of willingness to get like offensive
about it, like the not offensive as in your sensibilities, but
offens like on going on the offense about it and saying like
Trump's moving an armada over there. Um, how is this helping
America? Why would you be going why would you be send why wouldn't
you be running on that like asking those questions the whole
time? Why wouldn't you just be making it so that as the second
he actually because he's not he's not even appealed to the American
public. He's not I sure hope he's not going to try to start a
war. He's not made the case to the American public. You could
have been running on this the whole time, right?
>> And no effort whatsoever already. >> And I I'm
really not trying to do the flowchart memes or say anything like
that. Like I I hold the Trump admin first and foremost responsible.
Okay, let me get that stupid throat clearing out of the way before
I say this. But I really think that Dems's focusing on the procedural
aspect on doing this throat clearing of Ayatollah bad. I was
no fan of the you the IRGC bad and like starting with all of
these disavowels and not just going straight to the heart of
the matter which is that this is illegal and nobody wants it
and like doing all of this stupid. One, you're watering down
and undermining the message. It's too it like it's getting lost
in translation like what the criticism is or how angry you are
because you just seem like a you seem like you're like you're
kind of okay with it but you're just annoyed that he didn't like
dot some eyes and cross some tees which is unfortunately how
the American public views getting Congress on board with declaring
war at this point because every single president has used uh
military has engaged in military actions that they shouldn't
have um as the executive for one and for two they were not outspoken
nearly enough when it came to the destruction of the nuclear
facility. ities or the decapitation and extradition of Maduro.
They just weren't. And I think a huge part of this is Trump's
hubris in thinking that like, oh, I didn't get opposition from
my party. I got praised. And then the opposing party that's supposed
to do their whole job is to criticize me. I even had them kind
of praising me cuz they didn't like cuz Maduro bad. >> Yeah.
I think
and it's hard to I I unfortunately kind of agree on the Maduro
thing with um with Hutch that at least in terms of marketing
it to the American populace.
It sort of just looks like really cool to
and that that's probably not a place I would take a stand signal
against. But the the bombers over the Middle East and then the
this war I think you could win on very >> you have to because
there's there was like a creep that this this admin is engaging
in like every single time he he took those military actions and
he really didn't face that many that much like backlash from
it and it wasn't made an issue. I just feel like it just enabled
him to be to to go even further even further even further. >> Um
I I understand the slippery slope argument. I do understand that
like if you don't take a stand somewhere it continues to degrade.
I think maybe making like a like just making the comments but
not pushing it. I think on the because again it just it was a
they they kind of just got the guy. I actually don't I still
don't necessarily think that they that Maduro didn't want to
get grabbed. I still feel like there's a decent chance that he
just wanted to get out of his country and he'd negotiated an
exit >> that was happening. I know what you're saying that
like there's a reality to contend with as far as like meeting
voters where they're at here. To me, that was at the time where
they were taking the most drastic uh mass deportation actions
that they had in Minnesota, trying to do it in California, all
of that. All you had to do to point this out is saying, "Why
is Trump bringing more illegals into this country? When is I
going to [__] kick out Maduro? Why are we extraditing
foreign nationals to bring and try in this country? For what
reason exactly?" No, it's a domestic crime issue >> argument
too. I can tell you to to anybody who's like um sort of like
a reactionary in the middle person
that's a weak argument. I the strongest argument you have >> with
all of this stuff is American interest. How does it serve the
American interest and Venezuela? You can make the argument it
serves the American interest. You can't do that with Israel.
Like you you have to look at these people as if they're like
total psychos, right? Because they kind of are. And with with
Venezuela, you can make the argument it's in America's interest.
With with Israel, you literally can't. Oh, you can't with the
Venezuela. That is so it's it's not true. All of these voters
attitudes on this are a result. They're not a constant. They're
shaped by an entire architecture that exists outside of a voting
booth and through the media that they consume and the things
that are happening in the world around them. And the fact that
people that like more Dems weren't drawing attention to the fact
that like there are there's always going to be domestic blowback
blowback to these things and explaining in ways that are palpable
and that people already care about or showing how like this is
not in our interest like why are we me why are we engaging in
like uh regime change and and this or whatever like it's I actually
don't think that's hard to point out to Americans at all who
still largely have PTSD from the Iraq war. >> I think the
argument is coherent for why you can engage in this action in
Venezuela. I think the argument is coherent. Spheres of influence,
right? Like that this is somewhere close by. It's somewhere that
literally has all the infrastructure set up to power like the
Texas and Florida refineries right there. Like I think there's
a ton of reasons that you could defend this on economic grounds
on like sphere of influence grounds like basically forcing >> Monroe
doctrine. You're saying that there like the point that I just
made is not going to fly with them, but Americans are going to
be able to get the Monroe doctrine. Then I agree with Dustin
Suggs who's saying IDK man, none of these idiots know the first
thing about Venezuela. So reality is what you tell them it is.
Then it's at I agree with that and what you're saying sounds
like you agree with it. So then it's a matter of just who sets
the terms of who actually sets the narrative first.
>> Okay. So if it's No, it's not who sets it first, it's
who sets it more convincingly. Now, do you think your side is
going to be able to lie through their teeth better than their
side? Cuz they're going to make good points about how this is
actually good for the American people. They're going to make
good points about >> What good point did they make? But
what? Name one name one talking point that they made about Venezuela
>> that actually >> getting all the money. We We're
just going to get all the money out of Venezuela. We kick China,
we get all the >> [__] you, China. We get money.
>> Who said this?
>> Uh Trump, we get oil. We got the oil. We We're getting
oil. Repeating. >> And you're saying there's no counterargument
to that. And there's no there's nothing Democrats could have
said that's a convincing counter >> No, no, no. Make the
counterargument against what I said about getting oil. make that
counter argument and make it convincingly in a way where you're
not lying through your teeth.
That's going to be where it comes down to is how effectively
can can dem operatives make that argument against it with like
by lying through their teeth and how well can you do it because
right now the thing that makes me feel joy in the world is having
to watch
Trump sick offense go and say 40 my 47 years my 47 years right
cuz it's so obvious how stupid they look to everybody involved
and I think Dems arguing against the Venezuela stuff look very
similar and I think that there basically just comes down to how
well you can lie and And I think it's really hard to to lie and
say no no we're not going to get oil out of that really hard
to like or like there are points you can make but ultimately
it comes down to like on the >> the counter >> argument
is that this Venezuela intervention to that would not even be
a substantive rebuttal to that it would just be drawing attention
to the fact that this is just one of many interventions that
this admin has taken uh during his short tenure and his second
term. Okay, this was after the Argentina bailouts. This was after
the Iran strikes. This was after him flirting with taking Greenland.
This was after him talking about annexing like or like Canada
or whatever. Like saying, "Hey, when does the America first thing
start, dude?" Cuz you you're talking about it's it's just like
adventurism abroad. And you always say it's in the name of America,
but it's not.
Except like I it's just very obvious that expansionism like being
being expansionist trying to take Canada Greenland works into
the like a yeah America ego attitude that people have and that
bombing Iran for Israel >> I think these people just believe
what you [__] tell them cuz Republicans were against
us and then as soon as they did it they were for it. >> Sure.
Portoella is a good argument that it's the same thing as uh because
I now that I think about it this is the way um
is the way I was trying to frame it at the time too is they declared
war in Iraq as well
sorry declared war they declared victory in Iraq as well and
it was anything but that right so the long-term consequences
the not knowing the long-term consequences then maybe you can
work it into adventurism like anti-adventurism
anti- um invent interventionist
stuff
in that way it's like oh yeah like we have no idea how it's going
to go >> because here's what they because again >> if
you say we should be you you prey on the fact that people are
skeptical of intervention following Iraq war the Iraq war and
Afghanistan war the first thing that they say is but this is
different cuz this is our sphere of influence this is not the
Middle East it's like okay what makes it different they'll start
to describe how Venezuela is literally more stable than the Middle
East and they're not Muslims which is a stupid argument to say
that that's why it's meaningfully different so it's like okay
so it's not Muslims and because and so we're we're engaged adventurism
and intervention that's illegal in a country that's stable. Why?
>> Way closer and way cheaper in our backyard. That's that's
why. Way closer, way cheaper. >> And you have no count
you have no counter argument to that that you can think of? >> I
mean, do you have a counter? >> Even though the America
Even though I'm asking you
>> to my own argument, way closer, way
>> I'm I'm just going to say way closer, way cheaper. I
I not going to pretend that Americans care about >> No,
you don't have a counterargument to yourself. You can't think
of one.
I I could probably think of one if I take a second. >> Okay,
think of one. >> Um, not one that I think is going to work.
Go ahead. >> Think of one that you think is going to work.
It has to be a good one >> to the fact that it's way closer,
way cheaper than in the Middle East. >> Yes. Are you buying
time while you search in an AI for an answer or what? >> No,
I'm like I literally just said >> You keep repeating back
to me, but you're not answering the question. >> Yeah.
No, you're asking me to come up for with an argument like against
something I believe. If I had a good argument against it, I wouldn't
believe it. But try to you it's it it's out there. It exists.
So try to you're asking me to come up with it on the spot. You
didn't like the ones that I had. So I want to know what your
answer is because if you actually have the convincing answer,
then you should be able to to bring up the counter argument and
then still support your original
>> Yeah. Is is it going to be refugees? That's the best
one I could think of.
>> Refugees. What do you mean? that that like destabilizing
V killing or taking Venezuela's leadership destabilizes the country
and we end up getting a whole bunch of immigrants into America.
>> Okay. Why wouldn't that work?
>> Uh because obviously the whole point of getting money
out of that place requires it staying stable and America has
an interest in keeping it stable.
>> And so we're going to decapitate their leader and that's
going to keep it stable or sorry him. He's not
>> Sure. uh you take their leader out, you replace it with
somebody else who's willing to play ball with you and >> but
they didn't replace they didn't do that. What they did they did
that it wasn't even like true regime change because all they
did was extradite Maduro and then his VP was literally slotted
in immediately.
>> Yeah, but with the I guess the directive to play ball
with the Trump regime, right? Supposedly
>> Trump didn't even want the person who was begging to
play ball with him, the person who got the Nobel Peace Prize.
That was who everybody was suspecting that he was going to try
to install and he was like, "No, she doesn't have the respect
of the people." No. And then he just went with somebody else
from the Maduro regime. They didn't. They only got him.
>> Well, yeah, but why do we feel like that's the case?
>> What do you mean?
>> Well, you don't have to replace any of the infrastructure
that exists there that like literally all of the the bribes are
already set. Everybody knows what their their price is, right?
you just take out the top piece, shift everything up one one
rung and it's the same regime running just with the understanding
that Trump can come and grab their leader or hit the country
when he wants. >> But then then you can undermine the fact
that he's saying that like the whole Maduro regime needs to go
cuz it's like well obviously not because now you're collabor
you're still collaborating with them if that's the case and if
you're not then why did you just take out only him? Why didn't
you take out the rest of them if you were going to do this? >> Well
I think he is collaborating with the Maduro regime
>> is he? I haven't kept up with it since.
I Yeah, I think that's literally just that a bunch of Americans
are going to invest like money there getting their refineries
up to date and stuff, right? Except Exxon. >> It's as simple
as It's as simple as >> Oh, yeah. They were against that.
They were against them doing this like several of these like
massive oil
>> One of them One of them was and apparently in a way
that like uh Trump hates them forever now. Kind of funny
>> that could be pointed out too. Like you could point
out to the fact that like capital interests were not necessarily
aligning with Trump on this and so Americans should be skeptical
of the fact that like the fact that like these oil companies
themselves are not cheerleading this effort uh should show you
that it's not going to benefit America
uh domestically as far as like producing oil. >> And that's
not a good argument. Not a good argument. I think um because
people will say like I
>> No, it's it's sorry it's a fine argument. It's hard
to message that. >> It's hard to message that because I
know exactly how the populist brainw would work there. It's like,
well, yeah, they're not going to like it because they're not
going to get the profits or something like that. >> Wait,
wait, wait, go. So, >> I know that populist will say that,
but if you're we're just talking about like median voters or
like independents or whatever, not all of them are populists.
>> Oh, sure, sure, sure.
I do think that would be the general response though is yeah
they don't like it because um America's going to get the profit
from it or something >> knock down your original point
still make the same argument. Love it. Uh
>> uh wait what was my original point that you knocked
down? >> You just said like oh here's how populists will
react and I said well wait we're not talking about populist we're
talking about uh like media and independent voters. And you're
like I still think they're going to think that.
I think that is the median independent voter right now is like
fairly
>> I don't know reactionary just working off of their I
do think that is how most people see it >> different than
populist >> the reason the reason why >> because
some of that canform >> why is it called populism
>> because it's it's a it's really like a rhetorical flourish
that contrasts the elites against the many
but the way that that manifests one is different and two there
are plenty of people that consider them that are very very skeptical
of populism that are like centrists, fence sitters, independents,
median voters,
>> Did you just totally ignore the etmology of the word
to not did you just not want to say that? >> What do you
mean? >> I asked you what the um I I asked you why is it
called populism? >> I I I thought I responded. Sorry. What
do you mean? >> Well, you you you did one half of it, which
is the conflation against an elite, but it is basically trying
to bring up like raise up the issues of the common person. You
asked me what the median voter thinks. I'm guessing it's mostly
how is that not responsive to what you said thinks >> because
I'm trying to make the point that you asked me about the median
voter and I responded with well pe the popular thing the the
thing the most common person will think is this. >> It's
a I literally defined it as a rhetorical flourish not an ideological
predisposition that people hold. >> You don't think it
maps on?
>> Uh sometimes it does. >> You think it maps on
in this case? >> No. We don't have any data to suggest
that people were ideologically attached to Venezuela invention
like intervention one way or another which is why and I agreed
with you because I said it matters who like sets the narrative
first and you said no it matters who does it con more convincingly
but if you're like and I agree with that um it has to be both
in reality but the reason why I think Democrats had the opportunity
to message really really strongly against it uh is is precisely
because there was no like Americans don't really have strong
opinions on this either way, which is why getting to them first
is is, you know, of utmost >> I don't Yeah, I don't think
>> like most Americans reactions to seeing that we randomly
extrad like did a special ops uh in Venezuela and took out Maduro
for whatever reason. Um that was not something that I think the
average American was going like, "Oh, cool." when they saw that.
It's like, "Wait, what the It's like literally just confusion
until people tell them what to >> I totally disagree, but
okay.
What what's the American like predisposition to to Venezuela?
>> Oh, cool. Yeah, we're awesome.
>> No, I think that's protection. I >> think it plays
into like a ton of tropes about Americans that everybody finds
to be true. America,
uh, we're the world police. We are awesome. We are manifest destiny.
We are the best. We can do anything. We just grabbed your >> That
comes after it if it if it's understood as a success. if it's
understood as a failure, that's not the case. Like right now,
they're failing in Iran. And we're not just going, "Yeah, America."
It is like it is more unpopular than the Iraq and Afghanistan
war. Even like after years after years, like it took years for
Americans to turn on it.
>> Yeah, that's >> and especially because there's
no troops committed to the area. So, >> but again, this
is why I was saying that I don't think I don't think you message
against the Venezuela like operation in the same way at all.
I never said to do it the same way. I'm just saying that they
needed to do more messaging against it because you get this creep
um where the admin and the party feels more emboldened to uh
act more hawkishly and outlandishly abroad because they're facing
little they're facing no resistance internally from their party
and then they're fa then the opposition party is not doing anything
I think if you had foresight there, you could have easily said,
"I oppose this because I'm going to oppose when they go to Iran,
when they're going to go strike in the Middle East. I'm going
to oppose when they go to strike like Greenland or something."
Right? I think you could say, "I oppose it not because this was
unsuccessful or that it doesn't make us look good. I oppose it
because of how it will like I think if you had the foresight
to do that, that would be reasonable for sure. But unfortunately,
that's like um going back in time.
>> I don't know. I I don't think that would have been impossible.
Most people just realized that war with Iran seemed to be something
that was going to get pushed >> Well, I have to leave in
like 6 minutes. We're going to do a little bit more Pisco Ogre
snarking. >> Ah. Uh, yeah. Sure, sure, sure. >> Why
would they burn a a reconciliation vote when they already have
Dems when they already have Dems willing to fly? They've gone
on record in print media to say that they would vote for it.
>> How many US senators have signed on to have signed on
to supplemental?
There's I'm not sure accounting Slotkin and like five or six
other ones have already come forward and say that they are willing
to do it because quote unquote we're in it
>> There was an article in political came though, right?
You agree they're not
worse. That makes it worse. >> But you were wrong when
you said they need them, right? Cuz that's not true, is it? >> Okay.
Yeah. No, I already said I didn't consider I didn't consider
reconciliation, but like I said, I don't think I don't I don't
find it plausible that they're going to burn a reconciliation
on that. So sure I was >> Okay. So that's all
a side point because I will obviously readily >> I would
have fought Pisco on this if I were Ogre Boy
>> like do they have the do they have the >> fight
every battle and just like your influencers fight on everything.
>> All right. Go ahead. >> Noted improv comedian
just everybody.
Very funny. Um, I would have fought on this point specifically
because even though they have the majorities in Congress, it
does not mean he's presupposing that they would have been able
to whip the votes for any check that Trump wants them to cut.
And maybe they would, you should operate that off that assumption
because the Republican party largely falls in line with what
Trump wants them to do. But depending on how much they were asking
for and what they were asking for specifically, it's not clear
to me that every single Republican was going to be willing to
go along with this. So, they would need Dems to flip. So ogre
could have said like do they have the the majority? Yes. But
like do you think that if Trump advanced the bill right now when
they can't even get the save act off the ground even though they
have the majorities in both the Senate and the Congress uh that
like they're not just rushing through bills left and right. Um
do you think that this Republican party especially seeing how
poorly planned coordinated and the public backlash is to all
of this? Like, do you think that they're jumping up and down
to get just cut him another $50 million after the big beautiful
bill already gave him even more money for defense spending
for this war of choice that's not popular? I'm like highly skeptical
of that. I'm sure Pisco is too. And I think Ogre could have made
him content with that and he would have had to concede. Okay,
so maybe they have the numbers, but like can't say for sure that
just because a bill advances tomorrow in Congress that it wouldn't
get shot down. And then Republicans would say that they have
disagreements with it for like particular like stupid reasons
or whatever, but it would still ultimately be opposition. >> I
think there's like an added element in there that you could um
like I think I think they would get it and I think it would be
because
but I do think it'd be important to get those people on the record.
That's like >> Wait, because what? >> Just having
it. Well, I think Democrats would end up flipping to them to
get I I do think people would flip to fund whatever they needed
to go and do this, >> but I it would be important >> to
make up for the Republicans that won't go along with it. But
once they do that, they're helping give permission to Republicans
to do it because then there's bipartisan consensus and that always
makes it easier to justify to your constituents.
>> Like see, everybody's doing it.
>> Sure. I just think it would be important to get those
people on the record to be honest. And like the fact that we
can't get Democrats to be a unilateral front in all of Congress
saying we are not giving a scent to this admin for this illegal
war is an abomination and a huge indictment of the party. >> Yeah.
No, I totally agree. I just
Yeah. I That's one of those things where I'm just like, yeah,
it's been this way for a while. I don't know. They I guess this
has been
like Pisco's biggest issue. >> Well, like Pisco agrees,
but he like hates when you point it out. Or maybe he hates when
Jenk points it out.
>> He hates when non-principled
non-liberals point it out. Okay. When these non-liberals point
out that my liberals suck. Okay. Those are my liberals to criticize.
Okay. Hakee Jeff name out your goddamn mouth. Okay.
>> Well, he hates Jeff and Schumer. So, they're the like
sacri like they're the go-to like things that he points to. Like
I I call the Democrats all the >> I I on the most unpopular
Democrats that exist right now. Cool. >> Chuck Schumer
is a war criminal. I don't want him there at all. Okay. Chuck
Schumer is a war. I totally disavow him.
>> Well, his his uh criticisms aren't that soy. But
>> no, I'm sorry. It's the it's the BBNet and Yahoo point,
right? Where it's like totally performative. You like do a signal,
but it's not really indicating something. It's like it's like
a convenient thing that you could >> Yeah. I Hey, I criticize
Democrats. I [__] on John Federman. It's like you're
so you're so brave for John Federman.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. >> There are some Democrats
who are probably in support of the war and Democrats who will
probably >> not probably like they are even there. He's
hedging. Why is he hedging? He knows that there are Democrats
in support of this war. They have said >> because he because
he came from a certain Twitch political community where saying
concrete statements can always be like you could always be pinned
down on those and infinitely question. No, but he already knows
this because when he was reacting to the Jenk video, Jenk made
a claim about a Democrat that was already flirting with committing
money to this illegal war and he was like, "I don't know about
that. I need to see that. I don't know about that." >> Well,
he already >> and he pulls it up and he was literally saying,
"Yeah, maybe maybe I'll cut him a check for this."
think like Moscowitz is an example, >> Mhm. Yeah. >> Not
wanting to sign the the war powers resolution or whatever. >> Well,
he flipped. He like explicitly
I'm not denying that. So why is it relevant? I'm not denying
it. >> Why is 2024 relevant when >> I'll tell you
why it's relevant. I'll tell you why it's relevant to my point
because he's complaining. >> Because Jenk is a hypocrite
or the
Sorry, you say that again. >> Because Jen, he said like
he asked why is he's like I'll tell you why it's relevant and
it's like because you want to get a dunk on him on Twitter because
Jenk made a stupid prediction and you want to make you want to
rub salt in the wound. You want to twist his arm a little bit
and you don't want to hear it and you're also ass mad that he's
making criticisms of Democrats when he made a stupid ass prediction
like that. So you have to get that first and then you'll contend
with his argument. But you're still not going to be willing to
give him like any props for the arguments that he's making now.
I agree that that's how it seems in the tweets. I think there's
another element added here where Pisco is specifically like getting
kind of soy because he knows Ogre Boy has seen the actual parts
where he's criticized Democrats, right? And so,
do you know what I mean? I don't know how to get that how to
also include that without um
because it's not quite the same. I do think Pisco
should take into account that probably like Chank specifically
wouldn't even know that, right? But a lot of people on Twitter
won't know that he's sort of mad at Ogre Boy because Ogre Boy
is the person he can get mad at that would know that he's done
those criticisms somewhere else. Does that make sense that I'm
like trying to I'm trying not to totally
totally say that he is basically like denying or doesn't want
to to criticize those people until he gets the concession. But
I see exactly like that's the way it looks.
>> I don't know. I don't know.
>> I see why he gets annoyed. But >> problems with
more dems than just Schumer, Fedman, and Jeff. Yeah,
>> But like it's the he has like his go-to kind of rap
sheet of like positions that he's taken. And the way that like
the way he like gives himself credit for it is like people in
my like liberal audience got mad at me for this. So that means
that the criticism was intense, but that doesn't mean that that
just means that you have a liberal audience that doesn't tolerate
any sort of criticism of Democrats. So, the fact that you're
criticizing, you're getting [__] for uh Biden engaging
in flagrant corruption and and like pardoning his son, Hunter
Biden, tells you that like they're the ones that cannot like
you you have like attracted an audience that like cannot handle
any criticism of Democrats, no matter how unambiguously like
valid it is, right? But he'll point to that to be like, I get
so much from my audience for coming out against Dems. But it's
like, but you're not getting because you you're criticizing like
AOC or you're criticizing kind of like from the left or something
like that. You know what I mean? You're getting because you're
criticizing like the the the people that progressives want you
to uh
to criticize alongside some other
>> He's going to really do be putting himself up on the
cross sometimes, doesn't he? I I can you WOULDN'T IMAGINE YOU
COULDN'T POSSIBLY IMAGINE HOW much I get for defending Hassan
[__] on the global getting pulled aside global entry
thing. He kind of he really do like he's >> even though
he like always points out that Hassan lied. Hassan lied. Hassan
lied about things or whatever
>> or like with these criticisms like he always buttons
it and like it's fine that you do this. It's fine to like want
to contextualize these things, but he doesn't like it's very
rare that he'll offer a criticism of like the people that he
um that are harder to criticize without saying like but overall
they're better. Like there's always like this sort of follow-up
like relative statement
to make it clear that uh but like yeah like but Republicans still
worse though. But this other person crazy though. But Twitter
lefties going too far with the criticism though. It can never
just be handed out, you know. >> [__] flowchart,
man. >> That's showing up to do what I exactly want all
the time. He made a promise. Not that Democrats would be there,
of course, because he doesn't trust 95% of them. That's his view.
He promised that the right-wing populist base would be there.
That was his promise. And that's what I'm calling attention to.
I'm not denying that there are some Dems who are in favor of
the war in disgraceful ways. So you bring it up. Well, isn't
it true that some Democrats are willing to fund it as though
it's responsive to my
It's not responsive. >> It's responsive to his
>> What? To But you're talking to me. >> Oh, this
is the SP. This is the Spider-Man pointing at Spider-Man moment.
Now I see why this is >> so Ogre boy's trying to say, "No,
I'm saying you respond to his point. I'm making his point back
at you again." And PC is going, "But >> why are you why
are you saying this to me?" Yeah. Okay, I guess >> yeah
like but you have to be responsive to my non sequator.
>> You have to be responsive to my non sequator and then
we can proceed with the conversation. But that is Ogre boy's
entire point which is that but you are the one introducing the
nonsequator. We could just contend with the arguments presented
at hand. Instead you want to make it about a referendum on uh
Jenk's hypocrisy first and then we can get to the criticisms.
But that's you arbitrarily choosing to prioritize that above
uh saying above just contending with Jenk's arguments of which
there are already ample criticisms you could make of them right
away. You don't even need to bring up the cheap dunk. But it's
just it adds insult to injury and just say, "Yeah, I like getting
in the extra cheap dunk cheap dunk. Sumi,
>> this is like totally solved by Pisco just making the
dunk a different tweet and then responding categorically like
>> No, not even. It's totally solved by Pisco just being
like, "Yeah, that's what I'm doing. So what? Yeah, I want to
make this painful for Jen. So what? >> Why is he got to
kneel on Chank? Chank's like the strongest soldier right now.
We need Chank alive. We need Pisco's neck boot taken off of Chank's
neck. Okay. Unacceptable.
I don't know why he's Why has he got it in for him and Anna?
Especially Anna. Anna's better than Chank. Okay. Anna
Anna said she was >> He doesn't have it in for Anna. He
was like sing for Anna earlier in the stream before Ogre Boy.
He was like based Anna. Base Anna multiple times.
But I really need that. Um I really need her doing the rubbing
her hands so I could get it up there really quickly. >> Dude,
post word war debate. It's he's like been giving so much more
credit to Anakasparian. I think he really liked how she performed
at the against Pearl
>> I mean really
that's almost as unfair a matchup as the US Army. The US >> I
know. It's like literally being like, you know, I wasn't a huge
LeBron fan until I saw him dunk on like a high schooler. Okay.
Cuz Anna has always has remained a competent debater even since
her like unaligned pivot. >> Yeah, sure.
I Dude, I like watching her on I that actually unrelated point.
I don't know how much more of this we're going to get to, but
I think it's crazy how some of the Israel first Republican people
have gone after Piers Morgan for basically trying to like platform
anti-semmites when it's like I'm going to have the four strongest
like personally appointed by BBNet and Yahoo spokespeople on
with Anna and then Anna is going to decapitate all of them and
then basically people points like, "Oh, why are you such an anti-semite?"
Dude, it's it's crazy. He's like John Krikus and like three other
total like totally zogged out
insane people and she's fighting all of them at the same time
and then Piers gets blamed for when she wins. Like dude, I think
Piers is trying his best. He's trying to make this work for you
guys. That's crazy to me.
>> Is just trying to get clicks and views for himself.
>> Yeah, he is. But he's not trying to do it by basically,
you know, putting Israel on the back foot or he's not trying
to make Israel look worse. He gets like some of the best pro-Zionist
people that are around who will come on a show. He gets all of
them.
>> Like he had Nefali Bennett on. Like I'm sorry, is there
a better person? Is there a person who could better make the
case for Israel than like the number two in polling right now
to become the next prime minister of Israel?
I hope not. I don't know. It's just the idea that Chank like
platforms total clowns for his real side and then like makes
anti-Zionist look good. I don't think that's what he tries to
do. In fact, if anything, he tries to do the opposite.
>> As you're replying to him, >> he's making a valid
point.
am I so So, am I wrong that what you're saying isn't responsive
to what I'm
>> I'm It's responsive to How is it
>> It's responsive to the interaction.
Look, this is where I said like he asks a question, he starts
to answer and he >> Hold on, let me listen again. >> Am
I So So am I wrong that what you're saying isn't responsive to
what I'm
>> I'm It's responsive to
>> It's responsive to the inter.
And he's already interrupting him. >> It as soon as Ogre
boy didn't immediately capitulate, Pisco knew he was going to
He knew he was going to interrupt. Yeah. interrupt and like again
like shifting the goalpost like okay so you conceded on that
let me get to my like dude this is not a
>> many such cases I don't know this is this is old Pisco
this is again I bring up the same person so often but this reminds
me of the Pisco Rage Pope conversations
like Rage Pope wasn't like a slobbering
>> and Pisco sometimes would like get a conversation with
him rage Pope say two words and Pisco go banan this guy from
the call now ban him right now get him the out of here he would
like actually just start losing. >> Yeah. When are we getting
this for IQ dick [__] out of this call who doesn't
know what the [__] he's talking about cuz he's a
[__] hack.
>> It's It's very funny.
The little bit little bit of old school Pesco right >> Not
entirely right, but he's more right than wrong right here. >> But
you're not you're not saying that I'm wrong. >> I'm asking
you like >> are you saying I'm wrong in this comment or
not? >> Look at this. >> You're saying why are you
talking about this? Right. It's just it's just a >> No,
that's actually Have you not did you not hear from peace code
that those are weasel words, Mr. Prosecutor? That's like weasel
words. You're trying to get out of anything. You're not You're
not responding to him at all. Okay. You're just not responding.
You just >> Stop with your nonsense. That's
>> You just implied that this that he's like a prosecutor.
That That's crazy. That's crazy. Am I catching for No, the point
is he wasn't a moral. >> Rage Pope was smart. Pisco was
just like unhinged towards him and triggered over him. And there
came a point where just it was like if those two were in the
call together it the conversation was going to immediately devolve
into that like or into this I should say >> in his defense
rage Pope was not always the best speaker so like he would if
he was in text he was very smart but he then he'd talk and Pisco
does that to the best of people I I tried to argue with him once
that he should be ner Pope he wouldn't hear it okay >> I
don't like all this Pisco snarking Pisco is my Boy,
I get to do it. >> Is this Wait, is this not Is this
Is this Pisco snarking? I'm literally laughing about it. Although
I did tell him that like obviously people aren't going to listen
to you and you're just a total dude to them instead of actually
>> No, Pisco I agree with some of the points that Pisco
makes in this. Like so like I'm criticizing the way in which
he's navigating this conversation. It's not even about the arguments.
It's that he's he's brought Ogre Boy has come in. Ogre Boy is
not being aggressive. There's times where he's not being responsive,
but the way that Pisco tries to demand answers and accountability
from people in a conversation only makes them double down, triple
down more. But I don't think he cares about that because he's
literally, and he reiterated this on the last live and learn
that like when they were saying, "Yeah, we need to have more
like gentle discourse to get more people to our side." I already
knew before Pisco even piped up to say, "I think we need to bully
these people more. I think bullying is more effective." Because
that's what he wants to do. He just wants to like talk at somebody.
It's not really a conversation. He wants to just like pummel
them to the ground. He wants to uh like like smash their sand
like
>> Yeah, basically. I mean, conversations it like a good
debate is one where you're kind of like building a sand castle
with somebody, you know, like you're building towards something
like an understanding of each other's positions. And I realize
this is like, you know, Blood Sport, but like Pisco doesn't want
to do that. He just wants to smash everybody's sand castles and
being like, "No, not like that." >> That's uh
Yeah, that is that is super accurate. It's it is a lot easier
to do, too. I think it's it's actually kind of unfortunate because
Pisco you would think that somebody who wants to smash everybody
else's sand castle is incapable of building one, but he's actually
got a pretty good sand castle that he doesn't really get to show
off that much cuz he's not willing to like or he's actually good
at building sand castles,
but he's just like not very good at doing it
And if he could just figure it out a little bit, he would have
a lot better conversations sometimes. Yeah, I think that's a
that's a good way of looking at it. Normally when I see somebody
who does this, they are like incapable of building their own
sand castle. >> That's why they like Okay, so somebody
put Pisco Pibble and I think criticizing criticizing him on how
he tears apart chicken is really Soy. This is not I'm not pearl
clutching here. It's frustrating to watch because I know Pisco
is better than this and I think that he could be a more convincing
ortor if he got out of this mode. He so quickly like the conversation
devolves into this sort of like shouting match very very quickly.
And sometimes it's earned when it's somebody like Rob Noir, right?
Where that that's like you're matching the energy there, right?
But when it's someone like Ogre Boy, it doesn't make sense to
me. Not because Ogre Boy I agree more with his politics or anything
like that, but because Ogre Boy's energy is like down here and
Pisces is like at a 10. >> Yeah. I I know exactly. I've
watched him do the collaborative thing with other people before.
>> I actually I just realized >> Yeah. And he's more
convincing and better in my opinion when he is doing >> I
just need him to pretend. Okay. Okay, for 2 seconds, just pretend.
I know he feels rage right now, but if he could pretend for two
seconds that ogre boy was destiny, he'd get right into the right
like kind I'm going to be understanding and charitable. We're
going to build a sand castle mindset. >> Dude, if he would
just pretend that Hutch is ogre boy, we could have much more
interesting conversations.
But let's be real, the conver the way that he navigates the conversation
with Hutch is probably what you need to do if you want to even
attempt to have a chance at convincing any fence sitters or anybody
who's in Hutch's camp. It has to be that gentle. It has to be
the four-hour long conversation.
It has to be that slow.
>> And it's it like by the end of the Hutch conversation,
it was abundantly clear that the obstacle to that conversation
being productive was Hutch, not peace >> Yes. Yes. That's
you do need the
>> No, boy. You would It would go better with you if he
was just like that. If he was treating the conversation like
that, it would go better with you. touches um the leftist meme
not understanding anything ever. But also he makes the face of
not understanding which is even more enraging. So >> those
faces man >> more right than wrong right here. >> But
you're not you're not saying that I'm wrong.
>> Why you just need a leader? Convincing people is a waste
of time. No, I like the I like the pantomime we do where we pretend
that
99% of people aren't just total meat puppets that you just pound
your will into. Coer, I don't want to I don't want to totally
succumb to that yet. Okay. I like the idea that I I like my cope
where people actually have brains and they think through things
and I can convince them of stuff. Okay. I'm going to live in
that fantasy until I die. All right. Thank you. That's all.
Sorry. Major Nick Fentes fan saying that you just need a leader
who tells people the way it is is the exact opposite of what
you were arguing earlier.
>> I mean, not earlier today, but in general, I know that
that's true. No, earlier today this conversation about what's
good about counter messaging that you can and can't do with Venezuela.
Missy absolutely just btfed you on that. >> No, you you
were making the argument Koser's making on Venezuela and I was
>> No, you no you. No, you
>> okay. All right. >> You're hitting me with asking
you. >> I make that argument all the time. I just don't
like I I think the problem with Democrats is they have people
they have like a more intellectual voter base and so they they
lose people when they just lie blatantly that if they want to
be populist, if they want to actually do demagoguery, they need
to like actually appeal to the lowest common denominator and
then their part is going to shift significantly. And I have no
idea how that's going to work out. >> You want non- anti-semitic
zosting from >> I do.
>> I'd take anti-semitic dog posting, too.
No, but I think your ideal would be, and correct me if I'm wrong.
I thought you weren't a griper,
was the non anti-semitic. >> I want any sign that the people
in your government actually understand that they're selling out
your future for another country. I want anything. If it's anti-Semitic,
so be it. If it's not anti-Semitic, so be it. I want any sign
from your from your leaders that they understand that they are
destroying the hegemonic superpower that has protected democracy
and liberal thinking for like 150 years now. 100 years maybe.
No, maybe not 100 years. Yeah, somewhere around 100 years. Okay.
I want to understand that >> asterisk for some people.
>> I want anybody to understand that. Yes. For for me,
for people me and my kids and my parents and my parents' parents.
Say the 14 words.
>> Save the Imperial Corps. Okay. I want somebody to save
the Imperial Corps for the love of God. That's it. That's all.
>> are you saying I'm wrong in this comment or not? You're
>> It's not about securing. Yeah. It's not about the 14
words. It's not >> Well, when you said for me, for me,
for me, yeah, that's what I want. But I what I was gesturing
at when I said for some people, it's like I meant it's like largely
been for the benefit of like like white westerners. And so I
thought you were picking up on that, but you didn't want to go
so far as when you said for me. I was like, "No, just say the
14 words at that point."
>> No, I thought you meant for some people like, "No, I
I didn't pick it up." Anyway, I didn't pick it up at all. No,
I'm like a multi-thnic, you know, multicultural coalition kind
of guy. That's all. >> You're a globalist. >> But
um >> that's what you're saying. Global globalist cuck.
>> But
listen, less immigration, but immigration is okay. >> You're
saying why are you talking about this, right? It's not >> that's
the position of the Democrats by the way. >> Um I
unfortunately the Democrats like >> that is objectively
the position of the Democrats. This is not up for debate. >> That
they harmed the like. So you could say like less immigration
but still immigration is the position of the Democrats. They
harmed that significantly by >> it's their that is their
stated and their actions.
>> Sure. the asylum seeker loophole being kept open as
long as it it was to allow for like totally historic um people
to come into your country over time. >> The sorry the asylum
seeker rules being laid out the way they were and being abused
by people and never evidence of abuse. You have no evidence of
abuse. >> You have no evidence of abuse. >> Okay.
No, you're right. It just there's a massive spike of people who
answered all the questions perfectly and were all totally legitimate
asylum seekers.
>> Evidence of an increase is not evidence of fraud. Yeah,
you're just doing the liberal thing. Um, can you show me the
study that says people were abusing the system? Nope. >> You're
using the straw man voice to avoid contending with the fact that
you made an argument that is not actually rooted in any reality.
And you can make that argument, but you are arguing from anecdotes
and and that is what you're doing and extrapolating from there.
I'm telling you that right now that I realize that Democrats
are perceived that way, but I'm telling you, you align with them
to a tea because when you look at the actions of past Democratic
administrations, not just their and their stated goals, they
want like it's it's the position you just outlined. It's like
less immigration overall, but still there can be some. It just
needs to be regulated. >> I again >> it's like contribute
it's like it's contributing to this >> authority on the
subject. Totally destroyed their authority on the
I could go I could go do more research on this. I think we have
argued about this before. We >> probably should have done
the research before you started arguing for it,
>> Typically the order it's supposed to go >> I've
Sorry. No, no, no. I've looked up this stuff. I'm saying the
same things I I wanted like I'm saying the same things I will
be saying. I just don't have the precise like um >> So,
you're going to do confirmation in front of me? >> Confirmation
wise. >> I'm doing confirmation wise. I'll bet
>> have the conclusion. You're like, I'm going to go work
backwards and when I come back I will
picked all my cherries are going to be in this basket and I will
present them to the same thing as the Somalia is the Somalians
in Minnesota and people saying that well there's no evidence
that's yeah there's no evidence because you explicitly endeavored
to keep it so there couldn't be evidence okay that that literally
the system was kept in such a state that evidence could never
be produced of any fraud
now I think that's through incompetence in Minnesota but that's
why there's no evidence and there never will be evidence but
there was obviously as most of the investigators will testify
to mass fraud happening. >> This is such cope. You're using
the absence of evidence as as evidence for your claim.
>> I'm using the documented complaints from >> You're
using the absence of evidence as evidence for your claim. That's
insane. >> Yeah. Just repeat the same thing over me instead
of actually listening to what I'm saying or >> because
you're affirming what I'm
>> I'm not. >> Yes. You're just you're just wording
it in a way that you think sounds better, but it's the exact
point that I'm making. But just say just say yeah.
Um, every every day you put like a dollar in a jar and
every day you put a dollar in this jar and actually I basically
get rid of the jar. I get rid of any way of keeping track of
it. And then you tell me you're continue to put dollars in the
jar and then I tell you, "Okay, well actually at the end of like
a month, two months, I say, "Can you show me proof that you did
it? The money's gone. There's no evidence. There's no log. And
I told you we couldn't have a log. We're not going to keep the
jar there anymore. You're not going to have a log of how much
you put in." And then I say, "Well, you can't prove it to me."
Well, actually, we I took steps to make sure that you couldn't
prove it. >> Okay, but then make that argument.
>> That's an argument I was making. You just weren't listening.
>> I know, but like when I'm sorry, sorry, sorry. Not just
make that argument, but then cons like concede the point to me
that you're you're still pointing to the absence of evidence
as being the evidence for it cuz you're saying that there should
not be this gap of evidence and that it was manufactured.
>> That's what you're saying. But that that in and of itself,
even though it's technically a negative claim, is an extraordinary
claim.
require extraordinary evidence. >> It's your fault for
for making the argument that that this is a problem that that
a problem has occurred that you've seen it happen and then I
I tell you no no there's no evidence of it. I'm not gaslighting
you. >> Wait, I didn't expect that to end on a question.
Start start again. >> I'm saying that like
I can I can point to a whole bunch of things happening like a
constellation of things and explicitly
people keeping it. So I can't answer the question. people have
been informed that the question is unanswerable that that you
are vulnerable to something. >> Then point to that, but
you have to point to the specific ways that Democrats actually
interfered with investigations or the ability to um collect like
data on this to to understand the the depths to which there was
fraud. >> Oh, it's not it's incompetence in this case is
just like genuine like incompetence and bureaucracy for the Somali
fraud. No, but the fraud is there. The fraud is there. the investigators
testify of the fraud being >> Okay, but that's different
than what you claimed entirely because you were saying that Democrats
like the impression that I got from what you were arguing is
that you were making all of this to mobilize the argument that
Democrats not like people have this impression of Democrats because
they go out of their way to shield and protect illegals from
accountability. But then if you're saying it's incompetence,
then that's still that's different than them going out to >> I
don't know what the immigration thing is. It's incompetence in
Minnesota because I watch them. But basically, would you if I
basically, how could I say this? So,
um, you have a democratic like, um, a democratic government.
Okay. >> And, oh, can I do this analogy? Essentially, you
have a cut and you're bleeding and I tell you, you're bleeding
from here. You need like this intervention to make sure that
things don't go bad. And you look at that and you're like a decision
maker. you have power and you go, "Okay, well, figure it out
at some point." And then you just keep doing that. And I'm like
pointing to the blood like you're bleeding out. It is a problem
that is continuing and persisting and you explicitly haven't
dealt with it over time,
right? That there is no thing happening that I mean with immigration,
Biden has the ability to put a stop at the border, right? >> Okay.
Okay. Here's then here's the heart of the the disagreement. Okay.
because I agree that there has been bipartisan failure on this,
but you think the solutions that they're not doing and the are
going to be the remedies that bring about uh like lowering immigration
and it's completely asked backwards cuz I know what prescriptions
you have and they lead to an increase in illegal immigration.
I promise you an increase in undocumented people being in the
interior of the country. >> The bleeding to be staunched
for a period until things are figured out. >> Yes. Staunch
the bleeding until you can actually figure out how to do the
surgery or the intervention.
I don't know exactly how to do that in the system. In the immigration
case, you like pause, right? You pause everything >> so
you can figure out why the system is clearly being used in a
way that's totally unprecedented. >> But we know >> pausing
it.
>> Or like we we know how to how to fix this. Like it it
really is a lack of political will because people are no there's
a lack of political will because the same people that want to
that are angry about that are the most angry about immigration
only want punitive responses to it and because they are presupposing
that that's the only way to crack down on it. But it's not it's
like a Chinese finger trap. The more that they try to resist
it and the less that they're willing to provide mass amnesty,
provide legal pathways to citizenship, the the more that they're
going to have to deal with the monster of their own creation.
like they don't want to hear that that is the the the reality
is that the way to lower this paradoxically is to open legal
pathways for people to do this. So you can it's it's an administrative
thing. It's not like a criminality thing. >> Yeah. I I
just
I disagree but I would have to >> I know but you have nothing
you have nothing. We'll get into it later but you have absolutely
nothing on your side. >> What do you have? >> All
data will support any argument that I make once we get into this.
I absolutely promise you >> the data. the data, right?
What do you want to talk about? Bill Clinton and what actually
led to the explosion of the undocumented population? >> I
want your research, your data that you have that shows this.
>> Sure. And can you provide me, while I'm doing this,
can you provide me the data that shows that more that closing
the border, Can you show me that closing the border is actually
going to lead to the thing that you said it would, which is a
decrease in illegal immigration, and so we can figure out what
the hell is going on, even though that's never been the case.
I honestly yelled over you there, so I didn't hear. Could you
say that again, and I'll listen this time? I apologize for yelling
over you.
>> Forgive you. I said, present the data for you or for
for your argument that closing the border is going to be the
thing that allows us to figure out what the hell is going on
and reduce illegal immigration into this country while I get
my data. >> It's it's not going to Sorry. It's obviously
not going to help you figure it out immediately, but you could
go back and evaluate the numbers you had and figure out what
metrics you need to track going forward so you can figure it
out, right? But when you when you argue back and forth about
what to do, right, while people continue to pour into your country,
you're not keeping track of very well, right?
That's the problem. >> People continue to pour into your
country. Even the way that you frame this tells me so much of
where you're coming from with this. >> You don't like the
language? No, the language that you use. I don't I frankly don't
care about the language. It doesn't offend me. It just tells
me like what frame of reference you're coming at this issue from.
Okay.
>> People are pouring into this country or
>> It's like it's like highly charged language to >> they
were swarming they're swarming the country. Okay.
>> Infesting swarming.
>> It it was literally like it's like the Constantine Kissen
argument of like we have an unprecedented amount of this or whatever.
It's like sure it's always good. Like anytime that you have any
number of a thing that hasn't previously been recorded, it can
be described as unprecedented.
But the connotation of that is that it's like scary and bad.
And sure, if you want to fear monger surrounding it or you're
genuinely scared of people coming over the border and not being
accounted for in a very significant way, you can you can be those
things, but you're it's like emotionally loaded at that point
so much in a way that it really doesn't need to be. If you know
any of the data surrounding this, >> yeah, that's totally
fine. Uh, I could just say that there are unprecedented numbers
of like unskilled immigrants coming into the country who are
going to depress wages for the average worker
>> in certain sectors. >> But overall, they're not
positive to the
>> I realize that that's not >> GDP go up. I if you
let me finish I was going to say I realize that to the people
who are having who are competing with uh undocumented workers
for these jobs that they're not going to take much comfort in
the fact that yeah line go up GDP go up I'm just telling you
that like that it depends on the sector that you're talking about
that it's a reality for some and not a reality in others
>> trade agreements were fantastic for the overall American
economy
lost Democrats elections for like past
12 But are >> you think I'm not critical of those free
trade agreements? I wasn't in favor of DPB and I had issues with
>> not me. You shouldn't be critical, you shouldn't be
critical of those free trade agreements.
>> Do you think that if you are about to say because it
was good for the American economy, then you never understood
my argument in the first place and we can continue watching this.
>> Wait, no, no, no, no. You were saying that it's good
for the economy, this this immigration, and I was arguing that
it depresses wages for workers.
>> I agreed with you. Do you remember when I conceded that
point and I said in certain sectors because when people say they're
a net positive the operative word there is net that's an aggregate
of every single population or like a sector where immigrants
are are impacting it. I realize that but I already said to you
that that's not compelling to the people who are being squeezed
out and competing with workers that are undercutting them because
they don't have we don't have regulation surrounding these things
so they get to work for nothing. The real way to actually cut
at the heart of this is to penalize capitalists in this country
from hiring and employing a bunch of of >> Everybody shared
that opinion. >> Well, I share that opinion with >> fines
for people you're who are you're paying illegally or just basically
yeah make it so minimum wage. >> But the but the party
that is the most anti-immigrant, which is the Republicans, they
will never do that. They're not going to penalize the last thing
they're going to do is penalize capitalists. They will do mass
deportations before they even think about penalizing capitalists
in this country for hiring those labor because they're the ones
that pay the party. >> Sure. Sure. But you are penalizing
the capitalists by not reducing not diluting the labor pool,
not like diluting people's bargaining power, right? By not making
people more and more replaceable. You're like objectively helping
the capitalists there. >> Wait, sorry, say that again.
Was it was >> you're objectively helping the capitalist
by allowing like
by allowing like unchecked illegal immigration or or we won't
call it illegal immigration by unchecked migration into the country
um asylum seekers and both right you're you're literally helping
the capitalists >> yes but I never argued for unchecked
I never argued for unchecked immigration into this country
>> but that was happening essentially with the asylum seekers
right
>> that everybody was being allowed in as a >> but
that's not unchecked immigration
Okay. So you but you're doing a semantic game instead of actually
like contending with what I'm saying.
>> Oh, how is that respond to what you're saying? What
do you mean? >> Essentially uncapped migrants coming over
your border is what most people would refer to as unchecked immigration.
>> The idea that you hand them a ticket that says you have
to check in. Here's your number. You have to check in. Don't
don't you dare not check in. The idea that that's how >> Yeah.
But 90% of those people come back into their immigration hearings
>> out of out of the 10 million people who came in. Therefore,
they are checked. They are >> 9 million. You're telling
me 9 million had immigration hearings that they they continually
check >> I said of the ones that they're they're assigned
a court date and of the ones that have been processed or whatever,
then yeah, that's the case. But I'm not saying that 9 million
cases have have happened because that we don't have the infrastructure
and the administrative uh systems necessary and the just the
sheer bureaucracy to be able to process the claims. that that's
different than saying that they're not being processed or they're
being allowed to do whatever.
>> Okay, so you have a system that doesn't work and instead
of pausing until you can figure out how to fix that system. >> No,
we know what to do. We need more judges. We just we need to stop
putting money in alligator Alcatraz and towards ICE and towards
mass deportation. You need to expand the bureaucracy.
>> I know it hasn't happened yet. Why are you saying this?
I know. >> My argument would be that it's uncheck
my argument. >> But we know what needs to happen. You're
saying that we we need to stop everything to figure out what
needs to happen. It's like, no, you we already know what needs
to happen. We need more judges. We need more people. We need
more people in these systems to be able to expedite the processes
so they're not backed up. >> Yep. But you continue to help
the capitalists by forcing these by forcing or sorry, by not
pausing um immigration or migration while you figure out how
to get the sorry while you get the things passed, the money passed
to get more judges and make that stuff happen. >> Yeah.
as a short-term burden, but eventually if if you as a short-term
burden, that's going to that's objectively the case. But the
system right now benefits capitalists. So like both parties are
in favor of that if that's the case. It's not like some big gotcha
on Democrats. And that's that's they're both complicit in that.
>> But yeah, 100%. But that's why people are so mad at
Trump right now is cuz he literally said he was going to stop
it and he hasn't. basically totally
>> that's part of the reason why um a lot of people actually
thought it was like when you pull Americans ask like why are
you upset about this? It's because they actually believe that
he was just going to go after violent criminals and uh the worst
of the worst and they didn't like that he's going after Home
Depot people and aita and people in their community. >> All
right.
>> He was basically like no not like that. And they also
over like people have a warped perception of how many um illegal
immigrants like bring and commit crime in this country. >> Yeah.
I don't think illegal immigrants by and large do more crime.
I would say like most of my arguments would be upon it would
just be about labor pool. >> I know. But when you do this
like you have all these unchecked people just pouring into the
country pouring across the border unchecked or whatever. Like
what is that leading people to think that you you believe?
Um, sure. But I mean, now you've just said something about it
and I I pause and I say I don't need to use that
>> I say don't Yeah, don't use that language because like
there I know that you didn't hold that I knew that you didn't
hold that position, but when you use a motive language like that,
I'm like do you actually are like does >> immigrants have
no power? If I'm refusing to not use Okay, I did I did a like
30 minutes on this stream in a like New York voice. Okay. I I
if I refuse to be kind to them and and deal with their sensibilities,
you think I'm going to do it for illegal immigrants. Ain't no
Apac for illegal immigrants. Okay.
If I'm offensive, it's >> I'm an equal opportunity offender.
>> I'm offensive, it's just part of the
But I will pause and say like, no, I understand what you're saying.
Like I I understand the language argument. I am explicitly not
doing that because it's a stream and it's meant to be entertaining.
But if you check me on it at all, I'll pause and like give you
my explanation. say, "Yeah, I don't >> I can check you
on it. I want it to be your default because it's not you, but
like people the the powers that be, okay, the people in the Republican
party, money interest, capital interests, all of the Heritage
Foundation, Project 20 2025, like all of the fear-mongering surrounding
it is not leading people to the conclusions that uh or like to
even like the descriptive prerequisites for your argument. It
leads people to think like, oh, they must be bringing crime because
of like what he's talking about. That's like what the image that
starts being conjured up when they use language like >> I
disagree that unchecked migration means crime. I disagree. I
I would say >> No, no. I'm saying when you use rhetoric
like they're pouring over the country and like we're being invaded
and
>> I I think pouring is
accurate and I don't think that's quite but I would say I obviously
raised the um like the heat on the different words I was using
after that. If I was using stuff like that, I would agree.
invasion. I think I would agree. Um, pouring. I do think that
that basically goes to like it's a porest >> Pouring. It's
a porous border. How do you mean?
>> Now, who's doing the semantic thing?
>> It's I'm saying it's literally like they're pouring
it. There is no they're barely being restrained at all from coming
into the country that it is >> Okay. Then you have a proprietary
that it's practically like a proprietary
>> Pouring in a like unchecked way. What do you mean? What
do you think it What do you think it means? >> Sorry, I
shouldn't say that. Okay, the definition nominally is true. >> What do
you think it means?
>> wait. When you say when you say pouring, it sounds like
again like unchecked or whatever, but when you're saying like
it's I mean it's porous. I just mean in this sort of neutral
descriptive sense or whatever, but you know that the connotation
that that carries is that people think like holy [__]
we're being >> I mean, and also poor is not equal to like
porous. That's two different
Um, yeah, but I'm thinking of pouring through a civ. Like people
are there's there's migrants who are coming and they're pouring
into something basically at the border. You should be >> saves
catch like are the are the migrants the like matter in the like
stock that you're pouring? Doesn't a civ like catches the like
the the thick >> No, you're trying to you're trying to
block you're trying to restrain things and it's just a civ. >> But
a civ catches like a ton of stuff that like only the liquid goes
through. >> Migrants are the water. The whole point is
I would assume that the migrants are the matter, not the water.
>> The migrants are the water. >> Then what's the
matter in this case? What's staying behind? >> No, the
whole point the whole point is that it shouldn't be a civ. It
should be something that catches. It should be a pot or something.
>> The whole point is that you default to this language
because it's just what you're accustomed to and I want to break
you out of this habit.
>> Um, no. I could be made aware of it and I still think
it's I think I will always use language that is like heated but
not like I'm not trying to do the invasion thing. I'm not trying
to do these are like savage evil people who are coming. I don't
try to do that but pouring is accurate in my opinion and like
unchecked is accurate. I don't think that I don't think those
have connotations and I think I could use a lot stronger language
if I wanted to give those connotations off. I could use swarming.
I could use infest. I could use invade. They could use >> just
because it could be worse doesn't mean that what you're doing
isn't contributing to it
>> or reinforcing it. Yes, you could you could use worse
language, but I'm saying like it's it's you know a [__]
step away from it. >> Yeah. But I I think mostly people
So I don't mind this conversation because I think we talked about
substance already. Mostly when people police the language, it's
nothing
at all. I just I think it's I just think it's accurate and I
I feel like I can stand on it. I understand why it makes some
people upset, but I think I think you should probably look at
what happened with um >> Well, at least can you can you
agree with me that it is possible to use accurate language and
still nonetheless have the that language be
lead people to an inaccurate representation of >> I think
I think it's accurate language that leads to an accurate
>> And that's just where we have a fundamental disagreement.
>> You could use accurate language that leads to an inaccurate
representation. And I do think like invade would be a way of
doing this. That would be, you know, terms of the dictionary
definition accurate in some ways, right? Infest or swarming,
evading. Um there there could be ways to like describe this that
would be accurate in terms of a dictionary, but that they wouldn't
give the right >> How do you even quantify this? LOL. I'm
sure that there's been studies comparing and contrasting the
rhetoric and uh between
uh party members and like campaigns that consider themselves
to be more open to like pro- immigration or like pro immigration
or open to immigration reform versus those that are skeptical
of it and favor punitive >> I'm not sure that there would
be studies on that specifically, but I I'm not like totally against
the idea that like language shapes opinion. I just think >> As
long as I'm willing to like pause and
>> stop about it, stop and like talk it over. Yeah, I this
is the funny thing. Evil Giant Bravo. That's why I said the things
Johnny Bravo says, "Am I losing my mind right now? Have we not
gotten over this baby [__] with
But I think Aaron's argument with the anti-semitism stuff would
probably be something along the lines of actually the language
we're using like actually moves the the issue in the right direction
rather than with this it moves it in the wrong direction, right?
It's just how you feel about the issue.
Um, like if you were saying like Israel, you know, has way too
much control over our government. If somebody's doing like quote
unquote Zog memes, how bad is that? I >> actually am critical
a lot of the ZOG memes because it like not again it leads people
to incorrect
diagnostics and assessments of the relationship that exists between
this country and Israel and how money influences that and all
of that. I don't even think people should really talk about Zionism
that much. I think it doesn't it like moves the conversation
backwards instead of
What would you say people should say?
I think that given what people tend to be receptive to and where
kind of enlightened public opinion is with respect to Israel
and language that people understand is approachable is not resurrecting
and exuming terms like Zionism where we're getting into like
what is a and does the state's right to exist and when was like
all of the wait
can you let me finish then I can get to it. I'm saying the reason
why I don't like that and those are the reasons why and I was
about to say the positive argument if you had interrupted me
was that instead I use a language of international law, human
rights, talking about um abuses, you know, like things that are
basically universalist principles that people can get on board
with and talking about like lobbying and like not talking about
ZOG, you know.
>> Sure. Do you think lobbying gets to the heart of why
Benjamin Netanyahu is so much pull in the White House right now?
>> Um, you want me to start to it?
>> I don't know what you mean by get to the heart of it.
>> Do you think it like actually explains the whole picture?
Do you think talking about lobbying would give you a good idea
of how Benjamin Netanyahu >> No, it's like it's a constellation
of factors. That's one significant factor among many.
>> Sure. I'm saying like how do you describe that? Well,
I'm telling you right now it's comprehensive and that it would
just depend on like where like typically when people are introducing
criticisms of the of this relationship. It is not a comprehensive
seminar. It's like it depending on what you're interfacing with
the line of attack can be um better explained through lobbying.
Sometimes it can be better explained by like you know uh like
how Protestants like pro like like Christian Zionism sure in
like certain instances or whatever. But like I find those instances
to be very very rare.
>> Could you give me then basically how you would describe
why America has gone to war with Iran within like this framework?
Is that too much? That might be too much. I don't need you to
explain like everything, but just like uh how would you do it
if you needed to give like a five like a two-minute
explanation of why America's at war with Iran? I would probably
start talking about how we have like fanatical evangelicals that
believe in the rapture and those are uh interests that are very
very closely aligned with pro-Israel lobbies like Apac, J Street
and other individual um wealthy donors that um
all over like the like the main thing bringing them together
is like broadly being in support of the goals of Israel
as well as like American supremacy and dominance in the region.
And see I so for me yeah the funny thing is like for me like
I don't know how you
that feels like well I agree with basically all of that. I actually
do agree with all of that. Um I agree that it's like a constellation
of factors depending on how you weigh them slightly different
impressions but to me all of that essentially comes down to like
I could just say yeah Zog's essentially true and I think that's
like funny and also gets to the heart of the issue. Wait, so
you just say Israel instead of Zionist? Yes. Literally Zionist
is this abstract term that for that or it may as well be. Okay.
Because like the first thing that people do is take issue with
the way that you're defining the term and then they want to fight
on that. And you have to define so many things before you can
understand like what a Zionist is or whatever. And you don't
need to talk about any of those things to get people on board
with the most basic criticisms of this, which is that we probably
shouldn't have so much lobbying to begin with. And then the fact
that these groups are explicitly and overtly exist to just advocate
for the to advance the causes of another nation whether it be
Israel, India, Japan, Venezuela, Cuba, any sort of lobby, Russia,
any sort of lobby like this is highly problematic and it doesn't
just there's like a reason to have a comprehensive approach to
it beyond just wanting to be like anti-zog. It should be that
you're critical of lobbying period. explain why Israel is so
much more effective than all these other
>> because we like we were critical or not critical I shouldn't
say that but since the formation of Israel we decided to align
ourselves with them over uh other Middle Eastern countries and
then from there this like what feels like an intractable relationship
between the United States was created
between us and Israel and it's sort of just been the status quo
and you know that carries momentum that carries it forward into
um
every administration since Israel has been created
where like there's sort of a bipartisan consensus on like what
ought to be done there. >> I think there's like obviously
I feel like there's more than that but um I don't like >> also
we we we dictate the terms more so than they dictate dictate
the terms to us. America dictates the terms, but Israel has,
in my opinion, as a like primary first principle of their state,
like an understanding and respect for how
American politics works, what American culture like is, and how
to
shape opinions or to how to like make arguments in a way to American
politicians both through lobbying and through like private networking
that gets them on side and I think that they've always made a
concerted effort as a state
engage in that like aggressively more aggressively than like
any other country like they basically knew their ability to keep
their country safe came down to how well they interfaced in politics
with Americans.
um that was ushered in during the era of Manahham Megan and like
when they started to uh embrace a more like conservative flavor
of Zionism which to me is like contradiction in terms because
it's like saying there was like at one point like a progressive
version of this ethnationalist ideology but really at that from
that point on when they started to embrace those leaders with
the exception of Rabbine that was pretty much what set America
on the course that it is today with respect to that pivot. it
being made like a hard right one instead of one that was uh
a lot less um fanatical. I don't know how else to put it.
>> Sure. But from there like a consensus like like Lood
basically the Lood party consolidated a bunch of different conservative
factions that existed within the Knesset um so they could exert
more political power and finally have conservatives running Israel
instead of like like >> don't you know groups
>> I sorry that's one of the groups they literally like
I believe they partnered with Ethiopian despite historically
being quite racist and quite hateful towards them. Operation
Abraham. They airlifted these people into this country so they
could increase the population of Ethiopians in the country.
>> Oh, that makes sense. Yeah, that's like a I >> these
were like covert operations to like move all of these people.
>> Yeah. Okay. You know what I >> But then once they
got there, then they were like treated as like secondass citizens,
but they were they just like it was to like continue populating
the
>> Yeah. the opposition parties in Israel also in favor
of military actions over the last couple years, not just Netanyahu.
Yes. Yeah, we know. >> Yeah. you know, >> but I'm
saying that that consensus was forged uh with the rise of of
Lood and and other conservative factions like coalesing and realizing
that like given their parliamentary system like they needed to
put aside their differences and uh
come together to form this faction to finally defeat like the
more progressive like liberal Zionists that had um at that point
run the country. Like I don't think people realize like like
Bengorian and like the first
until what's his name Jabatinsky who's a revisionist Zionist
they were like
they were economically left >> wait well I mean I yeah
it's funny that it's I think Bean is literally um
he was literally like a not
disciple might not be the right word apprentice disciple Jabotinsky
it's just funny how it like it literally has been a line of
to bag and to
Chiron and
Eyepatch. Eye patch can't get the name in my head.
Why? Why? Somebody eye patch
or Hero. >> I'm going to let you with this one. >> Me
the name. No, not Cshaw. >> It's not Shaw.
>> No. Uh, those guys. And then onto Netanyahu. It's just
very funny how they've all just been like a line of the same
people.
>> Can nobody really give me this guy's
>> General Chiron. Chiron operated under
Nope. Nope. Nobody can give me the name. Oh well. Okay. Uh, cool
talk. All right. I Yeah, I feel like so everything you said is
like great, but then how do you make that like pop and be entertaining
for a stream? Because to me, I understand how if you're having
an argument or you're having a discussion with somebody that
breaking things down to their like constituent parts without
without using language that like leans in direction, that is
like the most effective way to build a joint understanding. But
in terms of just doing solo content, I do think leaning into
memes, leaning into other people's constructions, and even ones
that are possibly problematic or offensive is like key to making
like good content. So, I don't know how you walk the line between
collaborative. It's not I it's not about not wanting to offend
people. I promise you it's it's not about that. I don't care
about people getting offended. There are people that I want to
be offended when they hear these things. I don't mind being inflammatory.
It is about making sure that people are led to the correct uh
like understanding of this dynamic. And even though everybody's
like, "That's why you need Zog. That's why you need Zog." It's
like, "No, the people that buy into Zog fundamentally misunderstand
this relationship. They have not made the correct diagnosis of
what is going on
>> Yeah. Diane was who I was looking for. Yeah. Um >> and
like liberals don't have the answer for it either, but because
they're fundamentally pro- Israel because again like they have
found a framework that exists for them to have a set of talking
points that allows them to rhetorically posture as though they're
critical of it, but we already agreed earlier that it's all in
service of
uh a pro-Israel agenda.
It is it is not true opposition to it.
>> Yep. Yeah. Yeah. I'm just thinking of like I feel like
it is pushing in the correct direction with the Zog thing and
it doesn't lead to but I don't know I don't know what like sort
of like poppy thing that you could joke around with and have
fun with that exists that does get people going in the right
direction. Like I almost think that things are transgressive
because it possibly at least arguably can push people in the
wrong direction. So, I don't know. There's something there about
the crossover of like comedy and political analysis that to me
makes it quite difficult to
>> to not do something like that. And
Yeah. I I don't know. Do you you get what I'm talking about a
little bit? No, I I know what you It's like inversely correlated
with like the thing like the snappier and the better the just
so story is the the likelihood that it's detached from reality
like significantly increases and the fact that like it's going
to land. Yeah. >> Thank you for saying just so story. So
when you link me that chap a bit and you understood there that
it's like it's about the story first to me I don't know a better
story than the like basically Israel's is I cuz I don't think
Israel's like it's not magic magic doesn't exist they're not
mind controlling people it's like relentless diplomacy over decades
right it's like it's totally undermines it to try to use some
sort of like oh it's you know it's magic they control everything
no it's literally persuasion like like extremely
rigorously applied persuasion over
I think it's just I don't know how to fight against that without
using like the comedy and the thing that might push too far in
the other direction. And I don't know something funnier that
explains the idea. >> Well, that's why I I leaned into
the lobbying thing. That's why and I did say and I still maintain
that like it to me it is it it is the primary thing to go to.
Um because this relationship, there's a reason it doesn't exist
for other countries, but it just as easily could have been any
it didn't have to be Israel, didn't have to be um the like the
e the ethnationalist movement didn't have to be Zionism or supremacy.
It could have just as easily been um like
like I don't know if like literally like like Liberia or something
the Liberian lobby could have been just as big in like a slightly
different parallel universe, you know? >> I don't think
so.
But I don't want to get into it because I don't know how to discuss
the topic that I'm like hinting at. Um >> well, I'm just
saying like the other thing is that like and here's the thing
that the ZOG posters don't want to hear is the extent to which
anti-semitism has made this such a prickly like like Israel benefits
from anti-semitism.
Any any Zionist does if if you're fundamentally pro Israel, they
benefit from peril. They love being able to market themselves
as we're a homeland for no one no one else accepts us. We will
never be able to integrate into other countries like they play
into their own tropes to be able to >> hold on
there is uh and it's not I don't think like Jews should be targeted
because of any of this but there is something to it being an
ethnore religion and it being an outside group in a lot of different
societies that has persisted. So like and I don't know that like
the Kurds are the same. It's like they've sort of played a unique
role in history that leads to this moment in time and I I like
that's not I swear to God I'm not >> No. When I say like
>> but there is something going on there that is interesting.
>> Well like anti-semitism like how how do I explain this?
Like there are quotes from
uh Theodore Herzel. It's considered like the father of Israel,
right? Father of Zionism. Uh saying that like like the Jew and
the anti-semite will become friends,
right? like they will be like each other's friends
or like something like that. And when you search this up, the
first thing that comes up or like like is some quote contextualizing
it being like he was not saying that blah blah blah. It was like
no but like it's a separatist ideology. So he said like well
Nazism wants to get rid of us. We want to be away from them.
So we can use the fact that we are otherred to our benefit and
have a nationalist movement and it will be the Zionism and we
will play on the exist like very real and existing fears that
Jews have broad like worldwide because of this force of anti-semitism
that persists everywhere that you know any Jew is uh to be able
to bring people to our movement and we can get people who hate
us on board with it because again it's a separatist >> Don't
you want to get rid of us? She's okay with ethnostates, but only
for Jay's. No, I'm not. I'm I'm critical of any ethnostate or
any ethnationalist
>> Turn straight into a Zionist. That's awesome. So awesome.
>> But I I told you this. I said that they like your child
any any like ZOG posters are going to be triggered because they
don't want to hear that anti-semitism has been a force that has
like led this. It's the same the same thing that relegated Jews
to particular industries whether it be Hollywood banking and
like the reason why is because Protestants aren't allowed to
do money lending. So that meant that were the only ones that
could engage in usery which is why you saw like then just generation
and the fact that people tend to do like what their families
do that's not specific to that's like literally anybody. Um you're
going to end up with a disperate like over representation of
of uh people in these sectors. Yep. And then that contributes
to like >> corporate rating went. >> Yeah. Like they
were relegated to these things and then eventually
>> like they're they're marginalized to these roles in
society at a point where they are largely dispossessed or
um not privileged whatsoever. They're secondass citizens. But
then that dynamic became inverted at one point. uh do started
to enjoy more um social cohesion, integration, became wealthier
um and >> I think
>> to some extent I do feel like you are
>> I just I feel like a lot of like do you think Anakasparian
doesn't understand any of that? >> What does that have
to do with anything? Why would you think that I >> Well,
so that's something
said Zog is real. Zog is true. Our government is occupied by
Zionist. >> Oh, I think she understands some of it. I think
that she just she fundamentally misunderstands like who's in
charge here
>> and like the extent to which how and like how that power
is exerted and why >> she also believes in like a lot of
very very very similar to like um the man is in charge he runs
the house >> and it's like well there's somebody there
talking to the man all the time so to to like sort of just um
say that as if it solves the issue or ends the issue it's like
no there is there is something else happening there in my opinion
>> that like just because America calls the shots has the
official like last word. Like we just watch with Trump, right?
Although I do actually think Trump is probably more complicit
in this than he lets on. Um
the idea that it's like no, Israel forced our hand. Israel decided
they were doing this. The Qatar thing, Israel decided they were
doing this, right? I think there is something else going on there
where Israel does have like a lot of influence over the decision-m
of the >> especially in this administration but in a lot
of administrations it's because of the relentless pursuit of
that government of that that national interest in shaping American
opinion. >> It's part of that but it also has to do with
the fact that our head of state is like a denial [__]
that has put a bunch of sickopants in charge that he's getting
led around led around by.
So he like he was liable to get on board with lit literally any
and he like he only cares about money truly.
>> So he was li he's been led around by like many other
groups but this is obviously going to have a disproportionate
impact because of the existing relationship between this country
and theirs before he even set foot in that office. >> Simpo,
what's the advantage to America for the operation in Iran unfolding
currently? or he's arguing that um >> like Obama >> like
here here's an example.
>> Obama was able to get the JCPOA off the ground despite
Apac launching a $30 million campaign domestically
to oppose it despite the fact that uh BB Netanyahu literally
came to Congress uh even though Obama didn't want him to and
address them on the threat of Iran. Like there's nothing that
BB Netanyahu is telling the American Congress that they don't
know or Obama that he doesn't already know. And still in spite
of all of that and the fact that uh uh you know they were no
those two were not they were like friendmies um because maybe
Nanyahu was obviously no fan of Obama even before he like entered
office. He was always like very contemptuous of him. Uh there
were certain points >> racist. Well, yes, but there were
um other points where Obama still was able to like exert the
the final word over
like ending um Operation Castlead
for the phone call. >> Oh, sure. Yeah, I do think that's
the thing is I think um it's like persistent pressure for multiple
sources. Like that is it's not magic. It's literally just And
it's by the way, it's not even like blackmail most of the time.
I think it's like, hey,
we you need to go like BB Netanyahu went to university in the
States, right? It's like you have to go to America. You have
to understand how these people think because it's going to be
incredibly important that you can make arguments on why things
that benefit us benefit them too. You will have to understand
how to persuade them, right? It is that persistent level um amongst
like the Israeli elite of consistently wanting to know how to
make the best arguments to America, how to how to like basically
align the interests of the two countries. >> Well, see
if you know this, doesn't this cut against your sort of like
simple neat so narrative because like not that you weren't surp
like when I brought up the Obama thing, you weren't like wait
is that true? like you know that until this administration like
even with as pro-Zionist as Biden was, they were still a like
a thorn in the side at different points to Israel and like not
giving them everything that they wanted. There's I can literally
send you a clip of Blinken being like they tried to bait us into
this war with Iran and we weren't going to [__] it.
>> I watched that interview. Yeah, but I've never said
this. I don't think Zog solves everything. I said it's funny
and it put >> No, it's like rhetorically useful or whatever.
Yeah. >> Yeah. I don't think I don't think it's like a
true reality that Israel controls America. I've never thought
that. But I I also don't think most people, at least prominent
people, like Anna Kasparian for example, I don't think she thinks
that it's like Zog is totally true. I think it's like, okay,
this now we've reached a point where you can't even or you're
not even attempting. You're not even attempting to argue how
this is in the American interest. You're like literally lying.
You're literally repeatedly lying about how this is in the American
interest to try to actually explain to us what's going on here.
And that's like too far. And so at that point when that's happening
it's like okay yeah you are just controlled
and I don't I personally don't think it's like harmful to >> but
I understand that people don't like it. I I generalally >> okay
I found it I found it
>> but like okay but you think that people don't like it
because again just like soy or tell me if I'm wrong I got the
impression that it's like soy pearl clutching and like this emphasis
on political correctness when it's like no that it's just just
not proper. >> Sure. But I like would agree in the same
places that it's not proper. I just think it gets like 90% of
the message across in a funny way. You could say the 10% is really
important, right? Like saying that like obviously it's not direct
control. Obviously it's not just blackmail forcing people to
do what Israel wants, but that's literally not the way any politics
could work. You can't actually
you can't like shape opinion and and push people around in a
way that's like that overt. It just doesn't work for very long
over time. That's why there's so much push back on this operation
because there's just no way like the whole point of the Israel
America relationship is Israel is able to convince America that
they're out their interests are aligned and in this case the
interests are clearly not aligned and it's not working and people
are freaking the out.
So it's not like Israel could just make America do whatever they
want. That's that's just never been the case. Well, like in Trump's
in Trump's case, like he benefits he he takes actions that he
benefits from financially personally, which is why and he's he's
obviously like he's increased his net worth and so like he's
in bed with the Qataris and the Saudis and um like you know those
Gulf States are strategic partners to Israel. Also, I think it's
really just like the fact that between him being a cenog game
show host and that it's like, well, I haven't been led astray
so far that for the most part he's like gone along with all of
this and it's worked out in his favor. This is like the f the
first kind of time that I think it's like majorly blown up in
his face. Like he was really he was not getting any for his complicity
in the Gaza genocide or like how much he was accelerating the
conditions and the famine there. Um even though we were we are
party to that. Um, but you can like just undermine it so quickly
and it really just goes to show how like Trump is is seeding
an extraordinary amount of power unnecessarily
to Israel and just giving them whatever the [__]
they want uncritically with no conditions attached where previous
admins were unfortunately
um not attaching enough conditions and Biden's going so far as
to say there's like no red lines literally. But um you can see
market differences. Mhm. This is
I would if I were if I were somebody who was still Hassan, you
know, bothered,
I'd lose my over the on Israel, all >> Well, wait, wait,
wait. When what I was about to say is like the reason why Biden
took those actions is not because he stood to personally benefit
from it. It is literally it's his like it's his own um his own
uh record betraying him because like Biden pretty much is on
the wrong side of like so many issues which is why I was actually
surprised that he governed domestically the way that he did.
Every single major issue with the exception of like gay marriage
he was on the wrong side of
uh including Iraq and Afghanistan. But eventually he like corrected
course on that um and then he became a critic of it. But the
fact that he was willing to greenlight it in the first place
hor like huge indictment of him, right? So I wasn't surprised
that he went along with whatever the [__] Israel
wanted to do. Um but it's it's rooted not in the fact that like
BB is so persuasive. Like it could be the least charismatic Israeli
leader um or the most charismatic. The reason why Joe Biden supports
it is getting back to what we talked about earlier with the fact
that there was a status quo and a consensus that he was comfortable
with. he operated within and he stuck to that consensus and status
quoism and thought it would always serve America and did not
see the way that like uh that it like that status quo no longer
benefited us at all. And I think he he understood that too late
because he started to make rhetorical changes with trying to
posture as like reigning BB in instead of like a few years earlier
he would have been like leaning so hard into like what what Obama
did with like Israel has a right to defend itself during like
Operation Protective Edge and all of these other um incursions
that uh Israel launched into the Gaza Strip
uh time and time again during his tenure. But that was obviously
not going to fly because the temperature had changed. because
Biden is like a is a committed Zionist and like fundamentally
believes that like we still benefit from this. Like how do you
>> Well, I think what happened to him was basically BB
just lied, gave him references about how they treat people and
what they'd be doing and then they he just was probably caught
lying too many times. I think that's what caused because I I
remember reading an article about Joe like basically throwing
a temper tantrum at how maybe it assured him something wasn't
going to happen and then it did happen and yeah, >> I don't
know if it maybe had to do with Rafa or something. I it probably
had to do with um getting Aiden through Rafa, right? The Rafa
crossing
was really >> Yeah. I mean that it was just you know humiliation
after humiliation and just fell for it again award because Biden
kept uh not uncritically
but just making way too many concessions and not pushing back
on the
um on Israel when like they would like like I knew things were
going to be bad when not long like in light of October the October
7th attacks Blinken tweets out we need a ceasefire immediately
and then he quickly deleted that
and that it was Israel has a right to defend itself. I was like,
"Okay, we're just going to do the I guess." >> Yeah. I
mean, at least he didn't go to war with Iran, Biden. And I just
I do feel like there's a I knew I knew in my heart that Trump
would give Israel whatever they wanted going into this administration.
I'm just I'm I'm even shocked. I didn't think it meant war with
Iran. >> I I could have maybe thought it meant like strikes.
I never thought it meant war with Iran. Like I'm shocked. I'm
legitimately shocked where we are. >> No, because like
it's kind of like the difference between Democrats and Republicans
on Israel is the same difference that exists between Apac and
J Street. They're both fundamentally a pro-Israel agenda, but
like J Street favors
um I'm not it's not incrementalism,
but does understand that there is uh a resilience and an importance
on there being stability and undertaking these actions is actually
not in the benefit of it. like neither the United States nor
Israel
even like creating this amount of chaos and these cyclonic conditions
between and like fighting on all of these fronts is actually
not and and for Israel to be in this like state of warly
right between all of these different factions and and like countries
like that is not good you know they're fighting off Hezbollah
and the Houthies and they're trying to do a genocide and they're
also launching like a war against Iran like just insane like
any just even one of those is already like an insane thing for
a state to have to be engaged in, subject their population to.
Um,
but then like for them to do all of it at the same time, just
massively massively volatile circumstances that they're voluntarily
entering into as opposed to the people like like Democrats realizing
that like yeah, that's not uh like again they'll uncritically,
you know, pass them blood money for the genocide, but they were
like, "Okay, well, wo there, cowboy." Like one battle at a time,
okay? One genocide at a time. You can't go starting a war with
Iran when you're still doing the [__] genocide. >> Yeah.
Okay. And that's basically what Democrats are like. Hey, hey,
no Westbank expansionism and Gaza ethnic cleansing at the same
time. Okay. Just one. No, you can't go to Iran, BB.
I see. Got it.